COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE I WILL BE MAKING
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES THAT
WE'VE DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
CENTRAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
WHILE I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN.
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE TUNING IN
FOR THE FIRST TIME. AND THAT
FEEDBACK IS NOT GONNA WORK
SALAMI OKAY. I'LL TRY AGAIN AND
SEE IF I CAN CONTINUE WITHOUT
AN ECHO. SO I'M GONNA- LET ME
AGAIN SAY FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
TUNING I FOR THE FIRST TIME.
I'M GOING TO COVER THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY IN RESPONSE TO THE KOBE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. BY
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
THE SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND
OUR EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH MID MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY. TODAY FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN A
COUPLE OF TIMES TODAY AND RIGHT
NOW IT IS DISPLAYED. THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. THREE THREE EIGHT ZERO FOUR
SIX SEVEN. WHEN WE DO MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND SO WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LATIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO OUR NEW ONLINE
TOOLS SO PLEASE AGAIN JUST BE
PATIENT. SO THAT EVERYONE GETS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT
REPORTER. I'M GOING TO ASK ALL
SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. AND IN ADVANCE I
WILL APOLOGIZE IF I HAVE TO
INTERRUPT YOU ARE ARE ASK YOU
TO STOP TO SLOW DOWN. ORDERS
REPEAT SOMETHING AND- SO THAT
WE CAN GET IT FOR THE RECORD
HARM. SO BEFORE WE GET INTO
BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA WE HAVE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND AS A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES YOU
WILL NEED TO TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES FOR THE ROLL CALL
AND EVERY TOM THAT WE VOTE. SO
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH
HERE. GROW HERE KAMLAGER HERE.
I'M LONGER HERE LAYERED HERE
LAYERED HERE BATES YES BATES
HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE.
THANK YOU. SO ON IF THERE ARE
NO OBJECTIONS I'M GOING TO.
DISPENSE WITH SOME ITEMS
APPROPRIATELY THROUGH THE
CONSENT PROCESS SO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR THAT WOULD BE ITEM TO F.
THE APPOINTMENT OF MR REX S.
TIME J. D. AS MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION AND STATE
FAIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR GROVER
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE- MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL. GROW BY GROWTH I KAMLAGER
I KAMLAGER RA LAYERED HI THERE
I BATES HI HE'S AYE ATKINS HIGH
CONCERN THANK YOU I WILL ALSO
ASK IF WE COULD TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER THREE THE REFERENCE OF
BILLS TO COMMITTEES I WOULD
MOBILE. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED A MOTION HAS BEEN MADE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ROVE GROW BY KAMLAGER HI
I'M LONGER I LAYERED AYE
LAYERED AYE BATES ALL RIGHT IF
I CAN HI THAT'S CONFIRMING I'VE
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES. WE ARE GOING TO
TURN TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
WHO ARE REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND
WE'RE GONNA START WITH ITEM ONE
A. AND LET ME TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD IN
WAITING I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE- WE HOPE THIS
GOES SMOOTHLY AND QUICKLY- BUT
WE WILL GO TO ITEM ONE A. FIRST
AND THAT IS THE APPOINTMENT. OF
THE MISS MERRY L. WATANABE AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE- WELCOME
DIRECTOR I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
INVITE IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN- I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
INVITE YOU TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF OUR TECHNOLOGY ANYONE
THAT'S WITH YOU OR THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. GO AHEAD AND
MAKE YOUR OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN AFTER THAT WE WILL GO
DIRECTLY TO- THE COMMITTEE AND
MY COLLEAGUES. FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SO WELCOME. IN YOU
HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY. OKAY
ALL RIGHT WELL JUMP RADIANT SO
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE A FEW OPENING REMARKS
BEFORE ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS. BUT FIRST LIKE TO
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
pJOINING ME VIRTUALLY TODAY I'D
LIKE TO THANK MY HUSBAND DAVE
FOR SUPPORTING ME AND FOR ALL
OF THE BIG AND SMALL WAYS HE
TAKES CARE OF OUR FAMILY. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MY AMAZING DAUGHTERS KATIE
MORIN WHO INSPIRED ME AND
ENCOURAGED ME TO BE BRAVE AND
CREATE A BETTER HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM FOR THEIR GENERATION.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK GOVERNOR
NEWSOM IN SECRETARY GALLEY FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN
THIS ROLE AND TO DO WORK THAT
IS MEANINGFUL. FINALLY I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT LEADERS ARE
ONLY AS GOOD AS THEIR TEAM I AM
HONORED TO HAVE AN AMAZING
LEADERSHIP TEAM SUPPORTING ME
AND A WORLD CLASS TEAM OF OVER
HOT FIVE HUNDRED STAFF THAT
SHARE MY PASSION AND COMMITMENT
TO ENSURING CONSUMERS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE HEALTH CARE THEY
NEED. I'M HUMBLED BY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD THEM AND
COMMIT TO CREATING A CULTURE
WHERE WE CELEBRATE AND EMBRACE
OUR DIVERSITY ENCOURAGE
CREATIVITY AND INNOVATION AND
ALWAYS LOOK TO BETTER TO
OPERATE WITH TRANSPARENCY AND
HAVE HARD CONVERSATIONS WHEN WE
NEED TO AND ALWAYS SEEK TO PUT
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE CONSUMERS
AT THE CENTER OF EVERYTHING WE
DO. I SPENT THE MONEY THIRTY OF
MY CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE%
WORKING ON PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TO
THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AND I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE FROM CONSUMERS
ACROSS THE STATE ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT AND LIFESAVING IT IS
TO HAVE HEALTH COVERAGE BUT
THIS IS ONLY THE FIRST STEP.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT CONSUMERS
UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE THEIR
COVERAGE WITHOUT BARRIERS OR
DELAYED AND THIS IS AT THE CORE
OF DMH SEES WORK AND A CRITICAL
PART OF IMPROVING OVERALL
HEALTH IN ADDRESSING HEALTH
DISPARITIES. MY PRIORITIES FOR
THE COMING YEAR INCLUDES OF
SUPPORTING THE STATE'S RECOVERY
FROM THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
ENSURING CONSUMERS HAVE ACCESS
TO NEEDED UNTIL LATE CARE
ENSURING HEALTH PLAN ENROLLEES
HAVE ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AND LOOKING AT. HEALTHEQUITY IN
EVERYTHING WE DO. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TO
AND I LOOK OVER TO ANSWER YOUR-
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD OF SENATOR LAYERED AND-
ASK YOU TO KICK US OFF. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR. AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR-
APPOINTMENT. TO THANK YOU FOR.
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. I
HAVE A- AND I APPRECIATED THE
FACT THAT WE MET YESTERDAY
MORNING AND I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS I THOUGHT WOULD BE
GOOD TO. JUST TALK ABOUT IN
PUBLIC THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY AND ONE IS THAT.
WITHIN THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE DEPARTMENT IS REALLY
MANAGING MANAGED MEDICAL CARE
WHICH IS IN MANY CASES LOCAL. A
NONPROFIT THAT TO DO DIFFERENT
KINDS OF HANDS ON SERVICE. HE
A. N. LOW OF JUST DIRECT
PAYMENTS COULD YOU- JUST TALK
ABOUT YOUR OFFICE AND- HOW
WITH. OF LOOKS AT MANAGE
MEDICAL CARE ENTITIES HOW THEY
DEAL WITH THEM HOW YOU REGULATE
THEM. YEAH NO I PUSHED THE
OPPORTUNITY TALK TO YOU-
YESTERDAY AS WELL- SO I BELIEVE
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS SO
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE REGULATES ABOUT 96%
OF COMMERCIAL AND GOVERNMENT
ENROLLMENT IN THE STATE- AND
THIS INCLUDES REGULATING BOTH
COMMERCIAL PLANS AS WELL AS
THOSE THAT. RESPECT AND
MEDICARE ALSO MEDICAID MANAGED
CARE PLANS- WE REGULATE
PRIMARILY THE LOCAL INITIATIVES
WE DO NOT HAVE REGULAR
REGULATORY AUTHORITY OVER THE
COUNTY ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEMS
ALTHOUGH MANY OF THEM ARE-
LICENSE WITH US FOR. OTHER
PRODUCTS AND ONE IS VOLUNTARILY
LICENSE- THE BUT YOU KNOW WE
KIND OF HAVE A JEWEL REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT OVER THE MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS ALONG WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. SO DH CS. HAS
OVERSIGHT FOR THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM AND A LOT OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY
ADMINISTER THROUGH THEIR
CONTRACT WITH THE PLANS. BUT
OUR RULES THE REGULATOR- REALLY
AS WE LICENSE THEM SO THEY HAVE
TO MEET ALL THE REQUIREMENTS OF
ANY OTHER LICENSED PLAN SO WE
HAVE BOTH FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT-
WE MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
OTHER OPERATIONS ARE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE KNOCKED COMPLY WITH
THE KNOX KEEN ACT AND THEN OF
COURSE THE CONSUMERS. I'M HAVE
THE ABILITY TO COME TO OUR HELP
CENTER AS WELL SO THAT'S KIND
OF THE JEWEL REGULATORY
STRUCTURE WE DO WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR SISTER AGENCY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
ALIGNED IN OUR OVERSIGHT OF THE
MEDICAL PLANS. AND ARE THERE
EVER TIMES THAT YOU WISH TO
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS OR
OBSERVATIONS. TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW. OF THERE
MIGHT BE. THAT COULD BE DONE
BETTER COMING OUT OF YOUR- OF
THOSE. AGENCIES SURE- NO I MEAN
WE ALWAYS WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE KEEPING THE LEGISLATURE
IN OUR STAKEHOLDERS- INVOLVED
INCLUDED IN OUT WOULD BE HAPPY
TO MAKE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
AS APPROPRIATE- I WOULD SAY
THAT WE AT WE OBVIOUSLY WORKED%
VERY CLOSELY WITH DH CS ON THAT
BECAUSE THERE ARE- GENERAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH BUT REALLY ARE. ARE
OVERSIGHT IS JUST MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE COMPLIANT WITH THE
STRONG CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
OVERSIGHT REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE BOX. OKAY WELL I
THINK THAT'S JUST SOMETHING
WE'RE SIGNALING ARE INTERESTED
IN OVERTIME. AND THEN THE OTHER
THING I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU
ABOUT WE HAD A VERY ANIMATED
CONVERSATION ABOUT AND THIS IS
WHERE I THINK I WOULD BE
SPEAKING FOR THE CONSTITUENTS
OF MANY PEOPLE HERE. OVER THE
ISSUE. OF HEALTH PLANS THAT
ENTER INTO CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS THAT GO RIGHT UP
TO THE LAST DAY AND THEY SEND
OUT LETTERS TO EVERYBODY IN
THEIR AREA THAT. THEY MIGHT
HAVE TO FIND ANOTHER WONDER
CARE MIGHT AND- A AND I
DESCRIBE TO HAPPEN TO ME TWO
YEARS AGO WHEN. WHEN I LEFT
STATE EMPLOYMENT AND I HAD TO
GET A NEW HEALTH PLAN. THE ONE
I WANTED THEY WERE SENDING OUT
LETTERS CYCLE IS GOING TO BE
DISCONTINUED IN LOSS THIS
HAPPENED I DID TAKE ONE I
DIDN'T WANT BY THE TIME THE
DEADLINE PASSED THE ONE I
WANTED WOULD HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE BECAUSE THEY AGREED
TO DAYS BEFORE. AND IT SEEMS TO
HAPPEN REGULARLY. AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE THE HOSTAGES
ARE. BECAUSE IT IS IT IS
DEBATES BETWEEN. ARE EITHER
HOSPITALS OR PLANS FOR. OUR
HEALTH MULTI ARE COUNTY HEALTH
SYSTEMS. AND WE TALKED ABOUT.
YESTERDAY HOW THERE MIGHT B
SOME OPTIONS AND TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF THE
LEGISLATURE. WISH- OF KNOW HOW
FAR YOU WANT TO GO AND TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT THAT
I THINK IT WOULD BE A VERY
IMPORTANT THING. FOR THOSE OF
US BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING WE
HEAR ABOUT ALL THE TIME AS OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE. HELD HOSTAGE
IN THOSE SITUATIONS. SURE AND I
FOR THE TO CHAT ABOUT IT
YESTERDAY AS WELL AND SO REALLY
WHAT YOU'RE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN OUR ANY KIND OF OUR
OVERSIGHT ROLES IS BLOCKED
TRANSFER PROCESS AND SO THIS IS
WHERE. WE IN ANY OTHER PROVIDER
GROUP OR HOSPITAL- ARE
TERMINATING A CONTRACT THIS IS
OFTEN RELATED TO REIMBURSEMENT-
CONTRACT DISPUTES. AND THERE'S
A REQUIREMENT THAT THE PROVIDER
THAT HEALTH PLAN NOTIFY THE
DEPARTMENT AND FIND OUT WHAT WE
CALL BLOCK TRANSFER FINALLY.
WHEN MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
ROADWAYS ARE IMPACTED BY THIS
CONTRACT TERMINATION. AND SO
FOR PROVIDER GROUP TERMINATIONS
I NEED TO NOTIFY A SEVENTY FIVE
DAYS PRIOR TO THE TO THE
TERMINATION HOSPITALS ARE
THIRTY DAYS- AND THEN THERE'S A
NOTIFICATION. ISSUED ITS
REQUIRED TO GO TO CONSUMERS
SIXTY DAYS IN ADVANCE OF THE
CONTRACT TERMINATION FOR
PROVIDER GROUPS BUT FOR
HOSPITALS AND I THINK THIS IS
THE ONE THAT YOU REFERENCED-
THE NOTIFICATION GOES OUT AFTER
THE HOSPITAL TERMINATIONS
HAPPENED. OUR ROLE- WE DON'T
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DICTATE
WHAT. THE CONTRACT TERMS ARE
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE OR
REQUIRE PLANS TO CONDUCT A
CERTAIN PROVIDER GROUPS
HOSPITALS. BUT WE DO HAVE
AUTHORITY TO ENSURE THAT THE
PLANS HAVE AN ADEQUATE NETWORK
OF PROVIDERS AND SO OUR REVIEW
REALLY IS. WHAT WILL BE THE
IMPACT OF THE PROVIDER
NETWORKING CONSUMERS IF THESE
IF THIS CONTRACT TERMINATION
HAPPENS- WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE REVIEW THE NOTICES
THAT GO TO CONSUMERS SO THAT
THERE IS CLEAR AS THEY POSSIBLY
CAN BE. BUT ALSO THAT CONSUMERS
ARE AWARE OF THE THEIR RIGHT TO
REQUEST CONTINUITY OF CARE TO
CONTINUE SERVICES WITH THEIR
THEIR CURRENT PROVIDER IN YES
IT MEETS A CERTAIN CRITERIA- WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION. AND CONFUSION FOR
CONSUMERS- I WILL TELL YOU THAT
ABOUT 90% OF THESE CONTRACT
TERMINATIONS AND UP RESOLVING
THEMSELVES AND SOMETIMES SAYS
AFTER THAT THE NOTICES HAVE
GONE OUT TO CONSUMERS. IT CAN
CREATE CONFUSION AND
FRUSTRATION- AND THE UNKNOWN
OBVIOUSLY OF WHETHER OR NOT A
PARTICULAR PROVIDER WILL BE A
NETWORK SO- AS WE DISCUSSED.
YESTERDAY WE WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY YOU TO THINK ABOUT.
SOLUTIONS LEGISLATURE ON ON
SOME OF THOSE I KNOW WANT TO
SEE TO ONE WE TALK YESTERDAY OF
THIS SAME TO REQUIRE THAT SIX.
RIGHT AT THE TIME OF AN OPEN
ENROLLMENT- BEFORE SO PEOPLE
WERE DISLOCATED THERE WERE
DISLOCATED A TIME OF OPEN
ENROLLMENT WHEN THEY COULD
CHOOSE TO DO IT RATHER THAN
JUST BE IN THE MIDDLE OF SOME
PERIOD AND EIGHT EVEN THOUGH
THERE MIGHT BE A REQUIREMENT
FOR CONTINUITY OF CARE THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THE HOSTAGES
USUALLY KNOW ABOUT IT. OR CLEAR
ABOUT SO I THINK THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING TO EXPLORE IS WHETHER
OR NOT SOMETHING LIKE THAT
PHASED IN OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND IT IS ONE ANSWER TO
IT SO ARE. YOU SURE. WE WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION OVER TIME I KNOW
YOU'RE NOT LAST CALL ON THAT.
BUT JUST TO SEE IF THERE IS A
SOLUTION THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO PURSUE. THANK YOU KNOW WE
WELCOME TO WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE AMOUNT. GREAT WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION. THANK
YOU SENATOR I'M GONNA LEAVE
THAT ON YOUR TO DO LIST TO WORK
WITH US ON BECAUSE- I THINK
THAT WAS THE REALLY CRITICAL
QUESTION YOU ASK ON ALL OF OUR
BY HOUSE AND I WOULD NOT HAVE
THOUGHT TO ASK IT SO- AT THIS
VERY RELEVANT TIME. SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN PUT THAT ON
OUR TO DO LIST TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE THAT PROCESS
ANYTHING. SENATOR UP MEADOW
VICE CHAIR FEEL. WELL THANK YOU
AND CONGRATULATIONS. IF I WANT
TO MAKE SURE I STATUS ON WHAT.
I CANNOT. OKAY YOU GOT IT GOT
IT. A GREAT. ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND I'M LOOKING AT
YOUR BIO AND I'M THINKING
YOU'VE BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS
FOR A WHILE AND IT'S A VERY
COMPLEX BUSINESS I COME FROM
COUNTY GOVERNMENT WE HAVE CAL
OPTIMA AND I DON'T KNOW THAT I
EVER REALLY GOT MY HANDS
AROUND. THE HOW IT ALL WORKS
AND YOU HAVE OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT TO US AS YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU DON'T
OVERSEE BUT CERTAINLY IT IS A
IT'S A BIG BIG COMPONENT OF THE
DELIVERY OF OUR- HEALTHCARE AND
ENSURING THAT CHAU CERTAINLY
OUGHT IN THE EQUITY ISSUE. THAT
TO OUR LOW INCOME AND
VULNERABLE. HAVE ACCESS WHICH
TAKES ME TO THE QUESTION O THE
HEALTH EQUITY AND I KNOW- THE-
BUDGET PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL ON HEALTHCARE
IS TO CREATE A NEW HEALTH
EQUITY AND QUALITY STANDARDS
FOR HEALTH PLANS TO MEET. AND
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT. YOU KNOW
FROM YOUR FIRST. SOME EXAMPLE
OF WHAT WOULD BE THE AND
QUALITY. THE MIGHT BE KIND. FOR
THESE NEW STANDARDS THAT YOU
ARE WELL VERSED ON GIVEN YOUR
BACKGROUND ON. WHETHER THERE'S
SUCH. A GREAT DIVIDE AT THE
MOMENT SOMETHING THAT MAYBE THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO LOOK AT
ALSO. SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT YOU
KNOW JUST GO TO THE IT'S KIND
OF A TWO PART. IF THEY'RE OF
THE POTENTIAL FOR. A COST
PRESSURE THAT COMES FROM. WHAT
SEEMS TO BE A NOBLE- EFFORT
THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE TO BALANCE
THAT WITH THE COST BECAUSE THAT
PROBABLY IS A BIGGER ISSUE WITH
ACCESS- IN TERMS OF WHAT PLANS
OFFER SO. SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT
WOULD BE GREAT AND I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT HAVING. I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THIS ALL WEEK
BUT MY SCHEDULE JUST CRIED.
REALLY COMPRESS THIS WEEK AND I
DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO GET TO
YOU OFF ON A ONE TO ONE THAT
TIME HERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
YOU TO. SHARE WITH ME YOUR
THOUGHTS. ON ALL OF THAT.
JOURNALING AT I'VE BEEN WE CAN
CHANCE TO MEET EITHER BUT WHAT
TO FUTURE UP. SO ON THE HEALTH
ACCORDING QUALITY PROPOSAL THAT
THE GOAL HERE REALLY IS TO. NOT
CREATE NEW MEASURES WE HAVE A
LOT OF MEASURES THAT ARE
ALREADY CURRENTLY COLLECTED
ACROSS DIFFERENT PURCHASERS
WHETHER IT'S DH CS COVER
CALIFORNIA CALPERS WHICH I'M-
REALLY KIND OF HONE IN AND
REACH CONSENSUS AROUND TEN TO
TWELVE CORE MEASURES. THAT WE
CAN FOCUS ON AS A STATE TO
IMPROVE QUALITY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY HEALTH HEALTH
EQUITY. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT. IMPROVING
UTILIZATION AND THAT HEARINGS
WITH- YOU KNOW. COMPL WITH
CERTAIN SERVICE REQUIREMENTS AT
THE EXPENSE OF LEAVING BEHIND
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
IN PARTICULAR ARE COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR- THE PANDEMIC IS
REALLY HIGHLIGHTED THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON OUR
ON OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. AND SO THE
GOAL IS TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
WHICH MEASURE SHOULD WE FOCUS
ON. ON SOME EXAMPLES OF THAT
WOULD BE THINGS LIKE DIABETES
HEART DISEASE- COLORECTAL
CANCER SCREENING. IMMUNIZATIONS
AND THOSE ARE JUST SOME EGGS
AMPOULES WE REALLY WILL BE
LOOKING TO THE COMMITTEE OF
EXPERTS TO ADVISE US. ON ALONG
WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS AND OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATURE WHAT
SHOULD THOSE MEASURES SPEED-
AND THEN THE GOAL WOULD BE TO
SET BENCHMARKS OF WATER TO WE
WANT OUR PLANS TO GET WITH THE
FOCUS OF NOT LEAVING ANYBODY
BEHIND- AND SO THAT WILL BE THE
PROCESS THAT WE WILL GO THROUGH
TO RECEIVE. OVER SERIES OF
YEARS TO REALLY IDENTIFY THOSE
BENCHMARKS WITH THE ULTIMATE
GOAL. OF WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY- REALLY
BEING ABLE TO HOLD THE PLANS
ACCOUNTABLE TO ACHIEVING THOSE
MEASURES. DESIGNEE CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS TO REALLY MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON THESE MEASURES AND
ULTIMATELY TAKING IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS FINES
AND PENALTIES IF THEY DON'T
MEET THOSE BENCHMARKS. IN TERMS
OF THE COST OF THE PLANS ARE
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SOMETHING AS
BUT IN THE SECOND PART OF OUR
MISSION B. SIDES ARE PROTECTING
HEALTHCARE- PROTECTING
HEALTHCARE CONSUMERS IS
ENSURING A STABLE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS OF. THE COST
OF THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS
SOMETHING WE ARE ALWAYS VERY.
OF ALONG WITH THE IMPACT OF THE
PROVIDERS BECAUSE THE PROVIDER
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CONSUMERS
REALLY HOW WE IMPROVE. QUALITY
I THINK THE COST WILL COME. IS
IT BORDER. ACHIEVE AND- ON SOME
OF THESE MEASURES. AND TO REACH
MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT LEAVE
ANYBODY BEHIND. THERE WILL NEED
TO BE INTERVENTIONS AND SO THE
PLANTS WILL REALLY NEED TO
THINK CREATIVELY AND PROVIDERS
COLLECTIVELY ABOUT WHAT DO WE
NEED TO DO TO IMPROVE. ON
WHETHER IT'S GETTING PEOPLE IN
FOR VISITS MAKING SURE THEY'RE
COMPLYING WITH THEIR RATE THE
MEDICATION REQUIREMENTS- AND
ANYTHING ELSE REALLY TO IMPROVE
OVERALL QUALITY OF CARE- SO
THAT'S REALLY WHERE THE COST
WILL COME IN BUT IN THE LONG
TERM IF WE CAN ADDRESS-
PREVENTATIVE SERVICES AND LONG
TERM COMPLIANCE WITH SOMETHING
IS. REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURES I
THINK THAT'S WHERE WE CAN SEE
SOME COST SAVINGS IN THE FUTURE.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT TO VERY-
COMPREHENSIVE ANSWER TO MY TWO
PART QUESTION. WE ALWAYS GO TO
THE REIMBURSABLE SAW FOR
PROVIDERS. AND THAT'S WHAT
SEEMS TO TAKE A HERE AT TWO IS
WE GO FORWARD. THAT WE EXPAND
ACCESS BUT NOT PROVIDERS. AND
PROVIDERS TO DROP OUT BECAUSE
OF THE REIMBURSABLE ISSUE AND-
FRANKLY THAT GOES BACK TO I
THINK WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND- WE HAD MANY
PROVIDERS OUT SURROUNDING THE
CAPITAL AND- I DON'T THINK YOU
GUYS WERE ALL HERE AT THAT
POINT. DRIVE FOR LIKE TWO
THOUSAND THEY'RE DRESSED IN
THEIR WHITE COATS DEMANDING.
YOU KNOW AN INCREASE AT HAND
THE REIMBURSABLE FIGHT THAT
YEAR THEY- WE GOT SOMETHING IN
THE BUDGET THIS IS A YEAR
FRANKLY WITH A LITTLE MORE
MONEY THAT I HOPE. THAT WILL
HELP YOU DIRECTOR. AS YOU
APPROACH THIS ON THIS PROPOSAL
THERE IS MORE MONEY AND I THINK
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
CAN'T HAVE PEOPLE. NOT WANTING
TO GET INTO THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION BECAUSE IT BECOMES
COST- YOU KNOW NOT COST
EFFECTIVE AND ACTUALLY THEY'RE
PICKING UP ON A HUGE. YOU KNOW
BURDEN THEMSELVES N BY
PROVIDING CARE THAT IS NOT
COVERED. AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPACTFUL TOO. MANY
PEOPLE THE NEW PROVIDERS ARE
DOCTORS NURSES AT FEDERAL THAT
COME INTO THE PROFESSION. AND
FIND THEMSELVES BURDENED OUT
COMING OUT OF THEIR VARIOUS
MEDICAL SCHOOLS WITH A LARGE
DOUBTS TOO AND NOW THEY HAVE.
THE PLANS THAT ARE NOT
PROVIDING COVERAGE FOR THE
SERVICE OF THEIR GIVING AND I
KNOW THAT. WEIGHS HEAVILY ON
YOU TOO SO. I WISH YOU WELL AND
I'M IMPRESSED WITH YOUR
BACKGROUND I WILL ADMIT THAT I.
GO BACK TO THE ORIGIN OF THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM I WAS A SOCIAL
WORKER AT THAT TIME IT STARTED.
FRANKLY IN MY UNIT BECAUSE I
WAS. I HAD A TO THE DISABLED
WHEN IT USED TO BE DIVIDED THAT
WAY AND- MEDIC COUNTY MAN AND
REALLY HELPED US WITH PROVIDING
SERVICES TO OUR- OUR CASELOADS
THAT WERE REALLY. YOU KNOW
STRUGGLING AT THAT TIME TO GET.
CARE OUTSIDE OF A COUNTY
HOSPITAL. SO WITHOUT. AGAIN
WISH YOU WELL. AND- HAVE A
GREAT RESUME AND I HE THEY'LL
DO A ONE JOB THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR GROWTH.
AND THANK YOU MADAM FIRST
CONGRATULATIONS DIRECTOR ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT AND- I THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
SAID YOU ARE VERY QUALIFIED FOR
THIS POSITION I DO HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS- YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
KEY ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN
ADDRESSING IS WITH THE COKE IN
NINETEEN- PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
IT'S NEGATIVELY AFFECTED MANY
PEOPLE'S MENTAL HEALTH
INCLUDING OUR CHILDREN THE
KAISER FAMILY FOUNDATION- PULL-
SO THAT FOUR IN TEN ADULTS THE
UNITED STATES HAVE REPORTED
SYMPTOMS OF ANXIETY DEPRESSIVE
DISORDER AND NEXT TO THAT'S UP
FROM ONE OF TEN AND ONE IN TEN.
ADULTS PRE PANDEMIC AND THERE'S
ALSO BEEN A SPIKE OF OVERDOSES
DEATHS OVERDOSE DEATH BY 15%
THAT'S UP 15% SO- WHAT ARE THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE BECAUSE
THE DISTRICT- MY CONSTITUENTS
CALL CONTINUOUSLY ON THIS IS
THE IMPACT THAT. THE MENTAL
HEALTH IMPACT THAT THE RESPONSE
FOR COLBERT NINETEEN IS HAD ON
OUR CHILDREN I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW IF YOU COULD ADDRESS SOME
OF THE EMOTIONAL ISSUES-
CHILDREN'S EMOTIONAL HEALTH
ISSUES THAT THE RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED BECAUSE OF
SCHOOL CLOSURES AND IS THERE A
PRIORITY TO EXAMINE. THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- SERVICES FOR
OUR USE I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING
ON THE ADULT PORTION JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT THE YOUTH PORTION.
BEFORE YOU A- GIVE ME A SECOND.
I KNOW I CAN YOU HEAR. FRANKLY
IT'S SOMEONE'S MICROPHONE ON A
SOMEONE NOT MUTED OTHER THAN
THE SPEAKER. IF EVERYONE MUTE'S
THEMSELVES THAT MAKES IT A LOT
EASIER FOR ME. RIGHT. OKAY SO I
WILL ASK ANYONE THAT ISN'T
SPEAKING- TO MUTE THEMSELVES
INCLUDING- REMOTELY AND MAYBE
THAT WILL HELP I COULD SEE THAT
YOU WERE STRUGGLING TO HEAR SO-
I DO PAY ATTENTION AND LET ME
JUST ASK OUR MISS WATER NABI
YOU HAVE THE QUESTIONS STILL IN
MIND HI I'M SO SORRY I
INTERRUPTED YOU SO LET'S SEE IF
THIS IS BETTER EVERYONE MUTE
UNLESS YOU ARE ACTUALLY
SPEAKING AND- GO AHEAD WITH
YOUR ANSWER AND AGAIN FORGIVE
ME AND THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
INTERRUPT YOU. KNOW COURSE AS
SOMEONE WHO FREQUENTLY
FACILITATES MEETINGS YOU GOTTA
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY CAN HEAR-
AND I OF COURSE REFER THE
QUESTION IT IS PROBABLY THE
QUESTION THAT I THINK ABOUT
DALY- I WILL SAY THAT- ACCESS
TO BEHAVIORAL SERVICES IS AT
THE TOP OF MY LIST IN TERMS OF
OUR PRIORITIES AND IT'S FOR US
IT'S NOT JUST ADULTS BUT IT'S
ALSO CHILDREN THAT TWENTY SIX
MILLION CONSUMERS WHOSE- HEALTH
CARE WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO REGULATE- INCLUDES BOTH
ADULTS AND CHILDREN- OBVIOUSLY
THE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC BOTH
ON OUR ON OUR SOCIAL MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF A FOR
CHILDREN BUT ALSO ADULTS VERY
SIGNIFICANT- AS THE PARENT OF
JOB TWO TEENAGERS- I AM DALY
AWARE OF THE IMPACT OF WHAT
THIS IS. IS DOING FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND JUST THE
ISOLATION- AND JUST GOING
THROUGH A YEAR OF A PANDEMIC
THAT WE'VE NEVER EXPERIENCED- I
WILL SAY THAT- THERE'S A NUMBER
OF STEPS THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
TAKING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ENSURING ACCESS TO BE HERE FOR
A WHOLE SERVICES BOMB AS PART
OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THE
PARCHMENT. APPROVAL TO CONDUCT
FOCUSED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE TWENTY
FIVE COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS TO
REALLY DIG INTO WHERE THE
ACCESS BARRIERS ARE WE HAVE A
VERY STRONG CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LEVEL RELATED TO MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY DEPARTMENT'S DONE
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT. OF WORK IN
THE SPACE TO ENSURE THE I AM
ARE COMPLYING WITH STRONG. AND
PROTECTION. BUT- MY YOU ARE YOU
HERE RIGHT. UP ACTS ISSUES AND
BARRIERS TO CARE. AND WE REALLY
WANT TO UNDERSTAND RIGHT
TALKING TO CONSUMERS ABOUT
WHERE THOSE BARRIERS ARE AND
WHY IT'S JUST SO HARD TO GET
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES- IT
MAY BE THAT THERE'S CHANGES
THAT NEED TO BE EITHER
REGULATORY STRUCTURE CHANGES
THAT NEED TO BE MADE ORDER
THIRSTING SUCH PARTNER CAN DO
WITH OUR EXISTING AUTHORITY. WE
ARE LOOKING FOR CONSUMERS OF
VERY DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS- TO
HELP US TO INFORM THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS AND WHERE WE
SHOULD MARK. THE OTHER PIECE
THAT WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON IS
SB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE AND THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES THAT WERE
MADE THERE ARE. JUST SOME OF
THE REQUIREMENTS PARTICULARLY
AROUND THE USEOF CLINICAL
GUIDELINES THE PLANTS NOW NEED
TO USE. NONPROFIT CLINICAL
GUIDELINES THAT ARE
TRANSPARENT- BUT THERE'S NOT A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO
ESTABLISH THOSE GUIDELINES. SO
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING- WITH WITH
THE LEGISLATURE WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND WITH THE
HEALTH PLANS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB THIRTY
FIVE. SO WE HAVE A LOT IN OUR
TOOL KIT TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
CARE- I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T MENTION THAT WE ALSO
HAVE A CONSUMER HELP CENTER
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS.
THAT NEED HELP. OR HAVE ANY
CHALLENGES ACCESSING HERE WE
WANT THEM TO CALL OUR CONSUMER
HELP CENTER. WILL HELP THEM GET
THE CARE THEY NEED. ALL OF THAT
A- IT IS. ACUTELY TO BE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE- A GROW NEED WHEN
WE SEND CHILDREN BACK TO SCHOOL
IN THE FALL THERE WILL BE EVEN
MORE OF A NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT KIDS. FROM HAVE THE MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF THAT
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON. DIFFERENT
EFFORTS TO TRY TO ADDRESS THAT
AND THAT THE POTENTIAL
WORKFORCE ISSUES AS WELL SO
HOPEFULLY THAT WAS RESPONSIVE
TO YOUR QUESTION. ABSOLUTELY
MA'AM THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT AND SINCE MY- TO ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUES RT ASK THE OTHER TWO
QUESTIONS I HAVE I WILL PASS IT
ON. BACK TO THE SENATE PRO TEM.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROWTH
SENATOR COM LONGER. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MADAM PRO TEM AND-
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AS WELL WE HAD A
REALLY. GOOD DISCUSSION THE
OTHER DAY AND SO- I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- MY
COLLEAGUES DID ASK A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT- AND SO I JUST
HAVE ONE FOR YOU- AND WANTED TO
KNOW BECAUSE YOU TALKED A LOT
ABOUT A MANAGING COSTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT. NOT ONLY ARE
WE PROTECTING CONSUMERS BUT WE
ARE WORKING TO- GET RID OF AS
MANY BARRIERS AS POSSIBLE TO
CARE AND I FEEL LIKE I'M SPEAK
A LITTLE SLOWER NOW. BECAUSE I
WANT TO BE SURE THAT ARE STILL
MONGER FOR- CAN HERE- BUT I
WANTED TO KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON.
HEALTH CARE PLANS HAVING THE
OPTION TO OBTAIN
PHARMACEUTICALS ARE FROM
COUNTRIES OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED
STATES THIS HAS BEEN. A ROBUST
CONVERSATION THAT SO MANY
STATES INCLUDING CALIFORNIA I
HAVE BEEN HAVING. IN FACT LAST
YEAR I THINK THE GOVERNOR WAS
INTERESTED IN FIGURING OUT A
WAY THAT WE COULD GO AT IT
ALONE- BECAUSE OF THE HIGH COST
OF PHARMACEUTICALS. SO I WANTED
TO KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT-
GIVEN COST CONTAINMENT AS SUCH-
A CRITICAL ISSUE FOR SO MANY
FOLKS IN THE HEALTHCARE.
INDUSTRY NOT SURE NON AND I
THINK YOU KNOW AS AS AS A
DEPARTMENT THAT'S VERY FOCUSED
ON PROTECTING CONSUMERS BUT
ALSO JUST CONTROLLING COST THE
COST OF PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS
IT'S A VERY BIG ISSUE FOR US-
RIGHT. I DON'T KNOW THEY HAVE A
VERY STRONG OPINION I CAN
STRESS ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
ABOUT ACQUIRING PHARMACEUTICALS
OUT OF THE COUNTRY I YOU KNOW
I'D HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT
FURTHER ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THAT WOULD. WOULD HELP TO
CONTROL THE COST BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT ANYTHING THAT WOULD
HELP TO CONTROL THE COST FOR
CONSUMERS IS SOMETHING THAT- I
THINK WE ALL WOULD COLLECTIVELY
PEACE. ORDER BOB THE DEPARTMENT
HAS A NUMBER OF AREAS WHERE WE
LOOK AT THE COST OF
PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS EVERY YEAR-THE PLANT'S REPORT TO US ON THE
DRUGS THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST
COST HIGHEST INCREASING COSTS
IN THE HIGHEST UTILIZATION WE
ALSO LOOK AT HOW THAT. IMPACTS
CONSUMER PREMIUMS AND SO WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THIS AREA
WE ALSO CONVENED A TASK FORCE-
LAST OR NEXT IS BY TWO YEARS
AGO NOW AS A RESULT OF AB THREE
FIFTEEN- TO HAVE A TASK FORCE
RECOMMEND ARE THERE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING OUT AND SO I THINK THE
MORE WE CAN BRING TRANSPARENCY
TO. THE FLOW OF THE MONEY-
WHO'S MAKING MONEY WHETHER OR
NOT- PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGERS
ARE WHAT THE ROLE THAT THEY
PLAY IN THE VALUE THAT THEY
BRING SOUTH BEACH- I WOULD JUST
SAY WE ARE VERY SUPPORT OF ANY
OF ANY EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE
COST OF PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS TO
MAKE THEM WORK SYSTEM. OPPOSITE
CONSUMERS. GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I. HOPE AGREE- I JUST
WANNA ADD I KNOW THAT. PART OF
THE RESPONSIBILITIES AS- SORT
OF MANAGING AND MONITORING-
OFFICE CLOSURES AND HOPING THAT
THEY DON'T HAPPEN WE KNOW THAT
WE SAW A LOT OF THAT DURING
COLD BIT. AND I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THAT IN MY DISTRICT
WHICH- HAS BOTH HIGH INCOME AND
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WE SAW A
DOUBLE DIGIT- IN OFFICE
CLOSURES FOR SO MANY HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS FOLKS OFFERING
SERVICES TO COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AND TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TO LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES- AND THOSE ARE THE
ONES THAT MOST DESERVE- EQUITY
WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS HAVE
ACCESS TO CARE ON THAT IS
AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY AND NON
DISCRIMINATORY. SO I KNOW THAT
MAYBE NOT ALL OF THAT LIKE THAT
BUT I KNOW THAT ALL OF THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT- YOU ALL SORT OF
STRIVE TO ACHIEVE- AND HOPE
THAT YOU WILL CONSIDER THE
LEGISLATURE. A PARTNER- IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
WHAT WE CAN- TO ENSURE THAT
PROVIDERS ARE ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN ABLE TO
PROVIDE CARE TO ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS. DID YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT I THINK IT WAS
MORE OF A STATEMENT BUT ONLY
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO. HE
HAD NO I WILL I THINK IT'S A
REALLY IT'S A IT'S A GOOD POINT
IN SOMETHING THAT WE ARE WE ARE
MONITORING VERY CLOSELY WE
ACTUALLY IN RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC ISSUED- AND ALL PLAN
WATER AT THE END OF LAST YEAR
REQUIRING PLANS TO TELL US
ABOUT. I'M PRACTICES THAT HAVE
HAD A DECREASE IN UTILIZATION
OR OR REIMBURSEMENT OF MORE
THAN 25% AS WELL AS OFFICE
CLOSURES I'M MORE PRACTICES
THAT WERE SOLD SO WE'RE KEEPING
AN EYE ON THAT ON A QUARTERLY
BASIS THE PLANS ARE CONTINUING
TO FILE THAT WITH US- SO WORK
WE'RE MONITORING VERY CLOSELY
ABOUT THE IMPACT PROVIDERS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE AS WE RETURN
TO. WHATEVER DO NORMAL WILL
LOOK LIKE THAT CONSUMERS
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO A
ROBUST NETWORK OF PROVIDERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WHO WILL
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WILL START
WITH- TESTIFYING- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ANNA WE WILL START
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE SO LET ME SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY SPEAKERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
OKAY. SEEING NONE WE HAVE A
SECOND ROOM I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE
THERE AND WE DO NOT SO LET ME
INTRODUCE OUR MODERATOR WELCOME
YOU AND- LET YOU T. UP.
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT VIA TELECONFERENCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PERFECT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR AND S. U. T. SPEAKERS
UP I'M GOING TO SAY TO OUR
WITNESSES WE ASK THAT WHEN YOU
SPEAK. TO PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THE
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT.
AND AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR
COURT REPORTER PLEASE SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AND TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. ARE I AM
GOING TO LET YOU KNOW WE HAVE
QUITE A NUMBER OF APPOINTEES TO
BE CONFIRMED TODAY SO I AM
GOING TO HOLD YOU TO. THE
COMMENT OF YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
SO MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A LINE OF. EIGHT YEAR
MIKE DEVELOPMENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CONNIE CAL COTTO ON
BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF MERRY WATANABE FOR
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE THANK YOU
THAT WAS PERFECT THANKYOU
MISTER GADO THAT IS EXACTLY THE
ROLE MODEL FOR THE BEGINNING OF
OTHER SUPPORT COMMENTS LET ME
THANK YOU FOR THAT- MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE. CALL THE NEXT
WITNESS. A LINE OF FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIE
COLLINS PUBLIC POLICY OFFICER
WITH CLASSIFICA THE THIRD
CHILDREN YOU COULD SIGNIFICANT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
THAT ARE COVERED BY MEDICAID
AND COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS AND
DRUG JEFF BARBARA COUNTY. I'M
CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR SUPER
STRONG SUPPORT VERY WATANABE'S
CONFIRMATION DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NO
WITNESS. WINDS. SIXTY GOOD
AFTERNOON WHEN THE ACCIDENT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF MIDPOINT NABIS CONFIRMATION
AND DIRECTOR OF THE IMAGE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS MISTER MODERATOR. LINE
FIFTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
BERMAN NO WAY WITH WESTERN TEN-
ON POVERTY. IN ON THE
CONFIRMATION. YOU CUT OFF FOR A
MINUTE I'M ASSUMING THAT WAS IN
SUPPORT. MISTER VETERANS
DROWNED THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION. MISTER MODERATOR
GO AHEAD. IN A LINE OF. FIFTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ADRIAN CHILDREN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES WE
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY THE
CONFIRMATION OF MERRY ONE COULD
NOT BE FOR THE POSITION OF THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WITNESS.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR NEXT
WEDNESDAY. M. LINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RANDY PERRY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF MERRY
WHAT COULD NOT BE REACHED A
POINT OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. IN THE O.
LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TREAT THE STARK WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS QUESTION
OBVIOUS CONFIRMATION AT THE
NATURE DIRECTOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE
FIFTY YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM PROGRAM IN
MEMBERS CHRISTY WE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
DENTAL PLANS PLEASED TO BE HERE
TO SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF
DIRECTOR WATANABE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. ONE FIFTY
TWO THERE MIGHT BE THAT THE-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WITH MANY VEHICLES ALL OF THE
HALF OF AMERICANS POSITION
GROUPS HAPPENED HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE STOCK MARKET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS MISTER MODERATOR.
THE LION FORTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M SHELLEY REALART AND
I WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE PRIOR TO MY RETIREMENT IN
JULY I'VE WORKED WITH MERRY
WATANABE FOR OVER FOURTEEN
YEARS IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES AND
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALREADY
POINTED OUT ABOUT HER EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE AND THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM- SHE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY. AND INSURANCE
STABLE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM I'M THRILLED TO SUPPORT
HER- CONFIRMATION FOR ITS PART
CONTRACTED AT THE AGE OF YOUR
DIRECTOR AND I HOPE YOU WILL
SEE IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DIRECTOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PAST SERVICE AND EXTENDED THE
COURTESY GIVEN YOUR- TITLE FOR
A FEW EXTRA COMMENTS AGAIN WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND-
MISTER MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
ONE FIFTY THREE. HI MY NAME IS
ANTHONY WRIGHT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE HEALTHCARE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF VERY MUCH HAVE A IS
DIRECTOR DEAN HC A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ROLE AND BASED ON HER
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE AND
RESPONSIVENESS THANK YOU MISTER
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH- NEXT
WITNESS. ONE FORTY SIX. I'M
SURE MEMBERS JOHN LINGER ON THE
OUT THE ANTHEM BLUE CROSS HERE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. WHY NOT. SIXTY
FIVE. ONCE YOU HAVE YOUR NINE
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WILL
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
IN THE CALIFORNIA SENATE THE
KELP AT WORK WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT MISS MERRY WANT TO NOT
BE AT THE NEW DIRECTOR OF
DAMAGE THE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER WITNESSES AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A MOMENT.
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM. THE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT WE WILL NOW
TURN TO. AND FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS TO HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION. I WILL START RIGHT
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION FROM
THE PUBLIC. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHED THE PODIUM I WILL
CHECK ROOM ONE TWELVE. NO ONE
IS IN ROOM TWELVE MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE BACK WITH YOU
NOW WELCOME BACK. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO NECROMANTIC.
ONE ZERO. AND MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THIS TIME MISTER MODERATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL SEE
YOU IN THE NEXT ROUND OF
APPOINTMENTS- AND BE BACK WITH
YOU HANK YOU- OKAY I WILL COME
BACK INTO THE ROOM I SEE THAT
YOUR MIKE IS ON SENATOR LAYERED
YES I WOULD MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION OF MARIJUANA NAMBI
AS DIRECTOR. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH I PROVIDE KAMLAGER I. AM
LONGER I'D LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES ALL RIGHT IT'S AYE ATKINS
AYE ATKINS SIDE. THAT WAS
UNANIMOUS CONGRATULATIONS WE
WILL MOVE YOUR CONFIRMATION TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU ARE WELCOME OUR
COLLEAGUES LET ME ASSURE WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO VERY QUICKLY-
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK- TO SUPPORT OUR
COURT REPORTER WHEN WE COME
BACK- I WILL TEE UP THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD
APPOINTEES- UP FIRST TO MAKE
COMMENTS WILL BE MISTER BROOKS.
THEN MISS CAMP CAMPER VERDI
THEN DOCTOR HAWKINS AND THEN
MISS LOU RIANO SO YOU'LL BE
PREPARED IN THAT ORDER AND IF
YOU'LL BEAR WITH US FIVE MORE
MINUTES WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU HI AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR PATIENCE FIVE MINUTES.
MEETING BACK TO ORDER. GIVE IT
A MINUTE. MAKE SURE EVERYONE IS
READY TO GO. THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE PARTICULARLY-
THE CONFEREES WAITING I WANT TO
REALLY SAY HOW MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE I KNOW
HOW BUSY EACH OF YOU ARE- SO
THIS IS ITEM ONE B. THROUGH E.
THE APPOINTMENTS OF FOUR
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD- THREE PUBLIC
MEMBERS. ARE APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR MISTER RYAN BROOKS
MASALA HUNDRED COMPA VERITY AND
MISS LORI ROSE LUCIANO PUBLIC
MEMBERS AND DOCTOR RANDY
HAWKINS SO WELCOME. LET ME GO
AHEAD AND INVITE YOU TO START
THOMAS MISTER BROOKS WITH YOUR
COMMENTS INTRODUCED ANYONE.
THAT'S WITH YOU I SEE SOME
INCREDIBLE FACES THERE SO GO
AHEAD AND INTRODUCE YOUR FAN
CLUB AND THEN MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS. AND BEFORE WE GO TO
THE COMMITTEE I WILL GO THERE
AND TO- IT TO THE NEXT MEMBER
NEXT MEMBER ALL INTRODUCE EACH
OF YOU MISTER BROOKS THE RIGHT
HIT. THAT ANSWER HER PHONE
NUMBER TO THEM AND ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE I'M HUMBLED AND
HONORED BY THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TODAY I'M HERE WITH MY WIFE OF
TWENTY ONE YEARS CHRISTIE. AND
MY TWO BOYS TEENAGE BOYS RILEY
AND WRITER. AND I'D BE ALSO
REMISS BUTTON BAKER GOVERNOR OR
HIS CONTINUING TRUSTED ME. I'M
MY TO PAY SERVICE BUT MY TIME A
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION TO THE
NUMERICAL BILLBOARD. IN THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF PHARMACY SO
DOES THE PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION BUT NONPROFIT
NATIONAL FIRST RESPOND RESPOND
WHICH IS A FIVE OH ONE SEE
THREE THE PROVIDES MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT TO OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS ON THE FRONT LINE.
IN ON THE FEDERAL TRADE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT ADVISES
THE PUBLIC COMMERCE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE PONDERED ALSO TRADE
POLICY. THE SEVERANCE GOODNESS
HONOR TO HAVE WORKED UNDER AND
BEEN REPORTED BY REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATIONS. ON
A PERSONAL LEVEL I GREW UP IN A
SMALL COMMUNITY OUTSIDE OF LOS
ANGELES WITH PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
LOOK LIKE ME. I WAS TOLD I WAS
NOT GOING TO ACHIEVE OR
ACCOMPLISH. I HOPE THAT I
CONTINUE TO PROVE THE BROCK. I
HAVE BROWN BELIEVE THAT MY
COLLEAGUES DO SOMETHING THAT IS
BIGGER THAN OURSELVES IT WOULD
BE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY. FOR ME
TO HELP REPRESENT THE PUBLIC
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD. THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER BROOKS
AND TO YOUR FAMILY FOR JOINING
US TODAY. LET ME WELCOME MISS
ALESSANDRA COMPA VERITY AND ASK
HER TO MAKE OPENING COMMENTS
ACKNOWLEDGING THE ONE SHE WOULD
LIKE AND THEN- WE'LL- GO FROM
THERE WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALL
HUNDRED COUNCIL VERITY AND I'M
A RECENT APPOINTEES SERVING
JUST OVER SIX MONTHS TO DATE.
HAVING BEEN BORN AND RAISED IN
LOS ANGELES BY AN IMMIGRANT
SINGLE MOTHER FROM MEXICO AND
EXPERIENCE HEALTHCARE FROM
EVERY ANGLE AS A CHILD ON MEDIC
HOW AS A WHITE HOUSE AIDE TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN THEY
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WAS PASSED.
AND IN WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE MY
MOST RELEVANT PERSPECTIVE AS A
PATIENT THE CATALYST FOR MY
WORK AS A WOMEN'S HEALTH
ADVOCATE CAME AT A VERY YOUNG
AGE BREAST CANCER IS BEEN A
CONSTANT DRUMBEAT IN MY LIFE
DUE TO A HEREDITARY CANCER
MUTATION THAT RUNS IN MY
FAMILY. ROCKA MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER
LOST THEIR LIVES TO DISEASE AND
MY MOTHER AND TWO AUNTS HAVE
ALSO BATTLED BREAST CANCER AS A
BROAD COMMUNICATION CARRIER NOW
MYSELF AS WELL AS BREAST CANCER
SURVIVOR. I HAVE EXPERIENCE
FIRST HAND HOW VULNERABLE
PATIENTS ARE WHEN ENGAGING WITH
THE MEDICAL SYSTEM AND THE
VITAL ROLE THAT TRUST PLAYS IN
THE PROCESS. THESE EXPERIENCES
IN THE COUNTLESS PATIENTS I'VE
HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO KNOW AND
WORK WITH CATALYSE MY ADVOCACY
PARTICULARLY ORIENTED TOWARDS
INCREASING ACCESS IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES LAST YEAR I PRODUCE
A HELP DOCUMENTARY INHERITANCE
WHICH AIRED ON PBS. AND
INTIMATELY FOLLOWS A SURGICAL
JOURNEYS THREE WOMEN I'VE
HOSTED HELP SUMMITS OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS FOR YOUNG WOMEN
OF COLOR IN LOS ANGELES AND I
PARTNERED WITH PENN MEDICINE TO
LAUNCH A COMPREHENSIVE
INITIATIVE RAISING AWARENESS
AND PROVIDING SPANISH LANGUAGE
RESOURCES. THE LAST NEXT
COMMUNITY. MY PROFESSIONAL
BACKGROUND WORKING IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND AS AN EXECUTIVE IN
VARIOUS MEDIA COMPANIES I
SERVED A FULL FURTHER
ILLUSTRATE HOW CRITICAL CLEAR
COMMUNICATION WITH THE PUBLIC
IS AS WHITE HOUSE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF HISPANIC MEDIA MY
ROLE WAS TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A COMMUNICATION
STRATEGY. THAT WAS TRANSPARENT
AND CULTURALLY COMPETENT. I
CONSIDER THIS TO BE AN AREA
WHERE I CAN PARTICULARLY
CONTRIBUTE TO INCREASING OUR
REGION ACCESSIBILITY FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND TO THAT END I
AM ENTHUSIASTIC TO LOOK FOR NEW
WAYS TO ACTIVELY ENGAGE THE
PUBLIC. I TAKE MY
RESPONSIBILITY AS A PUBLIC.
MEMBER VERY SERIOUSLY THERE AS
WELL REASON ALONE THAT I AM SHE
AND I IS PUBLIC. LASTLY ON A-
NOW. I'M THINKING OF MY
GRANDPARENTS TODAY WHO DIED FAR
TOO YOUNG WITH LIMITED ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE IT'S IN THEIR
MEMORY THAT I PASSIONATELY
ADVOCATE FOR COMPREHENSIVE
PATIENT PROTECTION. I WANT TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
POINTING ME TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THIS CAPACITY
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PERFORM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
pVERY MUCH. LET'S GO TO DOCTOR
HAWKINS NEXT WELCOME. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF MY
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA I WANT TO
THANK GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM FOR
STRESS AND REAPPOINT ME TO THE
BOARD. I'VE BEEN IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE IN ENGLAND CALIFORNIA
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS. I
PROVIDE OSTLY PRIMARY CARE BUT
A LONG SPECIALIST AND INVOLVED
IN IN THE BLACK CARE A WIFE CAL
AS A PRACTICING PRODUCTIVE
BUSINESS INSTANT TWO ADULT
CHILDREN. I FAMILIES SUPPORTER
OF MY WORK AS A POSITION AS A
PUBLIC SERVANT. ALSO TO THANK
THE PUBLIC WHO COMES BEFORE THE
BOARD TO ENSURE THAT THE WORK
OF THE BOARD IS PROTECTIVE OF
THEM. THE MEDICAL BOARD'S
MISSION IS PUBLIC PROTECTION.
ALL OF MY DECISIONS OUR THROUGH
THE LENS OF PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
I HAVE TWO KEY GOALS FOR MY
NEXT TERM ON THE MEDICAL BOARD.
FOR SOMEONE APPROVED
TRANSPARENCY TRUST AND
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN MEMBERS
OF THE BOARD THE PUBLIC WE
SERVE. I FEEL THAT THE BOARD'S
QUARTERLY STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
AND THE PUBLIC OUTREACH
EDUCATION WELLNESS COMMITTEE
WILL BE ESSENTIAL CATALYST AND
CONDIMENTS. WE HAVE WORK TO DO
BUT I FEEL WITH FOCUS
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT WE
WILL SUCCEED IN BUILDING TRUST
AND TRANSPARENCY. SECONDLY I
PLAN TO PURSUE ENGAGE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL STUDENTS AND
RESIDENTS HE TRAINING PROGRAMS.
TO DISCUSS WHAT AN HONOR IT IS
TO BE A PHYSICIAN AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF HOLDING OURSELVES
AS DOCTORS TO A HIGHER LEVEL
ETHICS. PROFESSIONALISM I
BELIEVE THIS CAN CREATE BETTER
INFORMED AND MORE COMPASSIONATE
PHYSICIANS. THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION AFFORDS
PRACTITIONERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES
TO OTHERS OFTEN DOING EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE TIMES IT'S AN HONOR
TO PROVIDE MEDICAL CARE TO THE
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY BEFORE YOU HAVE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU DOCTOR HAWKINS
AND LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LEAST AND THANKING HER FOR HER
PATIENCE SALAMI OUT WELCOME
LAURIE ROSE LUCIANO WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
PRO TEM AND MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
LAURIE FRESNO BEE ON L. AND
I'VE BEEN SERVING AS A PUBLIC
MEMBER SINCE JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND AS THE
YOUNGEST AND ONE OF THREE WOMEN
ON THE MEDICAL BOARD I'M TRULY
HONORED FOR IT JUST PRIVILEGE
TO SERVE AN OFFER MY DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVE. AND THAT DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVE IS BUILT ON A
MULTITUDE OF THINGS ONE I BRING
TO THE TABLE THIRTEEN YEARS AS
AT BEING A AN ATTORNEY.
LICENSED IN THE STATE
SPECIALIZING IN INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY. IN THE TECHNOLOGY
SPACE AS WELL AS I BRING THE
SKILLS OF CONSENSUS AND
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING I'M DOING
MY WORK ON THE COMMITTEE IN
WITH THE COMMUNITY ON THE LOCAL
AND STATE LEVELS. AND LASTLY AS
PART OF THAT PERSPECTIVE- I'M A
PARENT OF TWO YOUNG CHILDREN
AND ALSO- PERSPECTIVE AS A
SECOND GENERATION IMMIGRANT
FROM A FAMILY THAT EMIGRATED
HERE FROM THE PHILIPPINES TO
SAN FRANCISCO IN THE EARLY.
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. AND OVERALL
I'VE WITNESSED FIRST HAND THE
IMPORTANCE AND IMPACT OF THE
WORK THAT WE DO AT THE MEDICAL
BOARD AND- I KNOW IT IT'S
DIFFICULT AND BUT I FIND IT
GRATIFYING AND WORTHWHILE. AND
QUITE HONESTLY THERE'S TWO
THINGS THAT DRIVE ME TO DO THIS
AND OTHER THINGS THAT AND THOSE
TWO THINGS ARE ONE IS I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT- IT ONE IT'S ONE
OF MY JOBS TO BRING MY TALENTS
AND EXPERIENCE AND BE A
BLESSING TO OTHERS. AND TO I
FEEL THAT- I'M DRIVEN TO LEAVE
WHAT I HIKES EVERYTHING SUCH
BETTER THAN IT WAS BEFORE. AND
SO WHEN I INITIALLY CAME HERE I
SET GOALS FOR MYSELF FOR MYSELF
US SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT TO
OUT REACH AND IF CONFIRMED UP I
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
TOWARDS THOSE GOALS FOR
SPECIFICALLY TO YOU ON ON THE
COMMITTEE OF OUTREACH AND
WELLNESS AND EDUCATION. AND
BRING SOME OF THE IDEAS I HAVE
TO LIFE. AND ALSO- YOU KNOW WE
RESPECT OUR AND FOR. PROGRAM
YOU OFFER THE INSIGHT AND
GUIDANCE TO ENSURE THAT YOU
HAVE PROTECTION FOR THE PUBLIC
IS GREATER AND PROMPT. AND SO I
WOULD BE TRULY HONORED TO
CONTINUE THIS WORK AND WHAT
WE'LL DO SO HUMBLY. AND WITH
ALL THE INTEGRITY THAT THE
APPOINTMENT DEMANDS AND LASTED
LIKE TO THANK. MY FAMILY FOR
ALL THEIR LOVE AND SUPPORT I
THANK YOU THIS WITHOUT THEM AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNOR WHO SEND
AND THE VILLAGE OF CHEERLEADERS
AND SUPPORTERS ALONG THE WAY
WHO HAVE ESSENTIALLY LISTED
NEED TO WHERE. I AM TODAY SO
THANK YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
TAKING YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I'M GONNA START
US SENATOR COME LONGER WITH YOU
AT THIS POINT AND- LET ME ASK
IF MY COLLEAGUES- IF YOU.
DIRECT YOUR QUESTION TO A
PARTICULAR- BOARD MEMBER WOULD
BE HELPFUL IF IT IS A QUESTION
TO EACH OF THEM. THEN I WILL
FACILITATE WHO GOES FIRST
SECOND THIRD FOURTH JUST SO
THAT WE KEEP IT ORGANIZED- AND
WERE HELPFUL TO THE COURT
REPORTER- AS WE FACILITATE THIS
SO SENATOR COBBLER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRO TEM UM I'M
THINK I'M GOING TO DIRECT. THIS
QUESTION TO DOCTOR HAWKINS I-
AND MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE HE ALSO
IS A CONSTITUENT NOW JOKING-
BUT I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU ALL
FOR GIVING ME SOME TIME TO-
MEET WITH YOU THE OTHER DAY I
THINK I SORT OF CHARACTERIZED-
THE MEDICAL BOARD AFTER READING
UP ON IT AS- A LITTLE BIT OF A
HOT MESS. AND IT CERTAINLY
ISN'T DEFAMATORY AGAINST ANY OF
YOU ALL AT ALL BUT PROBABLY
MORE OF A CHARACTERIZATION OF
THE WORK THAT IS AHEAD OF YOU
MOSTLY BECAUSE I THINK IN EACH
OF YOUR RESPONSES TO- THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU WERE ASKED.
YOU ALL REFERENCED GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND WORKING TO
BUILD BACK THE TRUST OF THE
PUBLIC AND I THINK BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- BUT ALSO PRETTY
DAUNTING. AND MY FIRST QUESTION
ACTUALLY- HAS TO DO WITH-
IMPLICIT BIAS AND SORT OF
RACIAL DISPARITIES- IN TERMS OF
THE DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS THAT
ARE TAKEN AGAINST THE DOCTORS
AND SO I'M GOING TO ASK DOCTOR
HOPKINS MOSTLY BECAUSE YOU ARE
GOING UP FOR REAPPOINTMENT- AND
PROBABLY HAVE A GREATER
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS THEN THE
OTHER THREE- PUBLIC MEMBERS. OF
COURSE IF THERE'S SOMEONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO IT
PLEASE FEEL FREE- BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT THERE IS IMPLICIT
BIAS EVERYWHERE- INCLUDING IN
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY- AND WE
ALSO KNOW THAT. THE
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS- THAT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN HAVE BEEN-
DISPROPORTIONATELY AGAINST
BLACK IN LATIN X. PHYSICIANS-
AND SO JUST WANTED TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON. YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
THINK THE MEDICAL BOARD CAN DO-
TO IMPACT OUR COMBAT IMPLICIT
BIAS- BOTH IN TERMS OF HOW
PHYSICIANS AND PHYSICIANS OF
COLOR ARE TREATED BUT ALSO
COMPLAINS- BECAUSE IT IS A
MATTER OF CREATING BALANCE ON
BOTH SIDES. OF THAT EQUATION-
BUT I THINK IT ALSO SORT OF
SUBTLY SPEAKS TO THE LACK OF
TRUST THAT HAS GROWN- FROM BY
THE PUBLIC IN TERMS OF HOW THE
MEDICAL BOARD HAS RESPONDED. TO
A NUMBER OF THE COMPLAINTS ND
INVESTIGATIONS THAT HAVE COME
YOUR WAY. THANK YOU REVEREND
HAWKINS GO AHEAD I'M SORRY TO
ME TO INTERRUPT DR HAWKINS GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
SO. ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
THE- DEMOGRAPHIC AFTER STUDYING
A CURRENT RISEN BECAUSE OF
COLLEAGUES OF MINE AND YOU KNOW
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY MEDICAL
SOCIETY WHO FELT THAT THERE WAS
DISPROPORTIONATE. DISCIPLINE
AGAINST THIS IS AN AFTERNOON
AMERICAN PREDOMINATELY
ORGANIZATION THIS ORGANIZATION
BUT ANYONE IS WELCOME TO JOIN-
AND SO WE'RE ABLE TO GET OUR-
THE CARD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
ALONG WITH OTHERS TO ACTUALLY
COMMISSION THIS THIS PROGRAM.
AND SO THIS WAS VERY VERY
INFORMATIVE AND INFORMATION
THAT WAS SUSPECTED BUT DID NOT
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE TRUE
WHICH IS THAT THERE WAS A
DISPROPORTION COMPLAINTS
AGAINST CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS
CERTAIN GROUPS. AFTER AMERICANS.
LANCER NEXT SURNAME INDIVIDUALS
AND THAT THERE WAS
DISPROPORTION DISCIPLINE AS
WELL- HI THIS CAME ABOUT
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO BACK. MANY
YEARS. HE COULD TALK TO
PHYSICIANS THAT LOOK LIKE ME
AND THEY WOULD SAY YOU KNOW THE
MEDICAL BOARD'S ALWAYS ON ME
THAT YOU KNOW DOCTOR SO AND SO
JUST GOT DISCIPLINE AND ALL
THESE SORTS OF THINGS OUT SO WE
HAD TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF. THE
SCOPE THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
SO WITH LIMITED AT THE TIME WE
CAN GET INFORMATION AND I'VE
MENTIONED THE OUTCOME OF THAT.
WHAT TWO THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED. IS THAT AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THESE FINDINGS-
IMPLICIT IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING- IS PROVIDED TO. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
EVERY TWO YEARS. AND IS OUR
RECOMMENDATION ALL BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. GO THROUGH THIS SO
THIS IS VERY INFORMATIVE. FOUR
THE MEMBERS. AS A RESULT OF
THE- RESULT OF THE STUDY. IN
ADDITION. WE REDACTED.
NONESSENTIAL INFORMATION THAT
MIGHT CONTRIBUTE TO BIAS FOR
EXAMPLE WHERE THE INDIVIDUALS
WENT TO MEDICAL SCHOOL WHERE
THE RESCU TRAINING. WOULD BE.
WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO MAY SUB
CONSCIOUSLY OR CONSCIOUSLY.
BELIEVE THAT A PERSON WENT TO.
AN ELITE INSTITUTION. BUT I
CAN'T BE AS GOOD AS A
COMMUNITY. INSTITUTION AND SO
THIS IS ONE OF THINGS WE ALSO
DID. SO THOSE TWO THINGS ARE
ACTUALLY BEEN. HELPFUL BUT IT
DOES NOT. GET RID OF. THE
PROBLEM OF BIAS SO MY
COLLEAGUES FEEL THAT- THIS PROM
IS TO RAISE- I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT TO. DRILL
DOWN ON LOOKING AT THE NEXT
STEP THE NEXT PHASE AND TO
ACTUALLY CREATE A STUDY. THAT
ANSWERS SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ANSWERED I THINK
THAT SOME OF THE ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
THE STAKEHOLDERS. THAT WE VIEW
THIS AS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
I DO I'M ONE OF THOSE. NEED TO
COME BEFORE THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND SPEAK OUT THEY NEED TO- GET
ON AGENDA. WE WILL. SET UP
MEETINGS WHERE THEY'LL BE THE
SUBJECT. OF DISCUSSION AND TALK
TO US ABOUT YOUR OBSERVATIONS
YOUR CONCERNS OR SUGGESTIONS TO
BE INCLUSIVE. IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU-
THIS QUESTION ACTUALLY IS FOR
MISS LUCIANO AND WE HAD- VERY
NICE DISCUSSION- I BELIEVE IT
WAS YESTERDAY AND I WE TALKED
ABOUT A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT I
MENTIONED THAT I WAS GOING TO
BRING THIS UP TO YOU SO- I.
WANTED TO SORT OF QUEUE THAT
UP- AND THIS WAS IN RESPONSE TO
A NUMBER OF SOME COMMENTS THAT
YOU HAD MADE OUT OF SOME TIME
AGO. AS IT RELATES TO OUR
VACCINES- AND I BELIEVE IT WAS
S. B. TWO SEVEN SIX AND- SO
JUST WANTED TO. ASK YOU TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
CONTEXT- TO THE STATEMENTS-
THAT YOU MADE- AND SO THE
QUESTION THAT WILL ALLOW YOU TO
DO THAT IS. YOU KNOW HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO BALANCE- THE
STANDARD OF CARE THAT MAINTAINS
OUR HOW CRITICAL IT IS FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH- FOR VACCINES AND
VACCINATIONS- WITH SOME PARENTS
THIS BEER- THAT THEY COULD
HARM- CHILDREN. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THAT QUESTION AND
ABILITY TO ADD SOME SOME
CONTACTS AND- WAS THE FIRST IT
JUST TO MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
CONFUSION- I BELIEVE IN THE
EFFICACY OF VACCINES IT AND THE
SCIENCE BEHIND IT. AND A FEW
YEARS AGO WE- WE HAD A BOARD
MEETING AND WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT VACCINES IN THAT CONTEXT
AND I HAD MADE A STATEMENT AND
MIND YOU IT WAS. MY SECOND
BOARD MEETING SO I WAS STILL
LEARNING THE ROPES THERE- AND I
MADE A COMMENT WITH RESPECT- TO
A CONSIDERING THAT. YOU KNOW.
HERE MEDICAL HISTORY OR GENETIC
HISTORY OR ACTUAL THAT VACCINE
INJURY IN PATIENTS AND THAT WAS
REALLY IN RESPONSE TO THE MANY
PARENTS WHO WEAR THEIR WHO ARE
EXPRESSING. THAT THEY'VE HAD
CHILDREN WITH WITH VACCINE-
INJURY AND THEIR CONCERN AROUND
THAT ISSUE AND SO THAT AND
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT IT WAS- BUT
WITH RESPECT TO- HOW WE WOULD
LOOK AT IT FROM A BOARD- ABOUT.
VACCINES AND HOW I RELATES AT
IT TO PATIENTS IS THAT YOU
DON'T. WHEN IT WHEN AND IF IT
COMES BEFORE US WE ALSO HAVE A
DUTY TO LOOK AT THE LAW AND
WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT FOR
OUR PHYSICIANS THAT THEY ARE
FOLLOWING- YOU KNOW THE
STANDARDS CARE WITH RESPECT TO
EXEMPTIONS THAT. PAYMENT BE
MADE RIGHT FOR VACCINES AND SO
THAT'S HOW I WOULD THINK ABOUT
THAT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
TONIGHT JUST MADAM CHAIR HAVE
ONE FINAL QUESTION THEN I GUESS
I WILL DIRECT THIS TO. MISTER
BROOKS AND MISS CAMP VERDE
RECOGNIZING THAT BOTH OF YOU
WILL BE NEW TO THIS BOARD- BUT
BOTH OF YOU SPOKE ABOUT-
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS- YOU BOTH
TALKED ABOUT- YOU KNOW BEING
MAYBE THE FIRST OR NOT SEEING
FOLKS THAT LOOK LIKE YOU AND
REALLY SORT OF CARRYING IN YOUR
HISTORY IS WITH YOU ON TO THIS
BOARD- THE BOARD IS ALSO
CONTEMPLATING A FEE INCREASE-
SO WE HAVE A FEE INCREASE ON
THE ONE HAND. THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED. WITH OF MEDICAL BOARD
I THINK THAT'S RANKED.
ACCORDING TO SOME REPORTS
THIRTY THREE- IN THE NATION-
AND THAT HAS BEEN STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY RIGHT WITH
OPERATING DEFICITS. COUPLED
WITH A VERY I GUESS ARE KEEN
SORT OF SYSTEM WHERE THE
MAJORITY OF THE MONEY AND THE
TIME IS ACTUALLY SPENT ON
INVESTIGATIONS- THAT MAYBE YOU
ALL DON'T HAVE- YOU KNOW YOU
YOU'RE NOT WITH HANDS ON WITH.
AND ALL OF THESE THINGS I THINK
ARE PART OF. THE COMPLEXITIES
OF BUILDING TRUST. WITH THE
PUBLIC. AND SO- WHILE I KNOW
THERE HAS BEEN A GREAT DEAL OF
DISCUSSION ON THE FEE INCREASE
AND SOME FOLKS THINK THAT THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT JUST WANTED TO
KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS AND SORT OF
FRESH EYES TO THE BOARD- IN THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT YOU WILL
HAVE AS BOARD MEMBERS. ON HOW
YOU WILL MANAGE THROUGH THOSE
COMPETING ISSUES RIGHT HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE A BOARD
THAT IS A FISCALLY- MAYBE NOT
PRUDENT BUT AT LEAST MANAGING
COSTS IN A WAY THAT MAKES SENSE
FOR CALIFORNIANS. WITH LIMITING
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT IT
TAKES TO INVESTIGATE THESE
CASES. SO THAT PEOPLE FEEL LESS
OUT REACHED. WHEN YOU'RE
PROPOSING FEE INCREASES THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY- DISSUADE NEW
pWANTING TO ENTER INTO THE FIELD
BECAUSE FOLKS FEEL LIKE I'M
GIVING SO MUCH AND NOT GETTING
AS MUCH IN RETURN SO WOULD LOVE
TO KNOW YOUR- TO BRIEF THOUGHTS
ON HOW YOU PLAN TO. ADDRESS OR
GUIDE THE BOARD- THROUGH THOSE
VERY MANY MATT LAND MINES- AS
IT RELATES TO SORT OF HAVING A
MORE EFFICIENTLY- OPERATING
BOARD- THAT'S BUILDING TRUST
MISTER BROOKS WHY DON'T YOU GO
FIRST AND THEN MISCONDUCT HERE
TO YOU CAN FOLLOW HIM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ALSO
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO MEET
WITH US- YOU KNOW THAT I DID
WAS APPOINTED ON FEBRUARY THE
SECOND SO I HAVE NOT ATTENDED A
BOARD MEETING YES- BUT I CAN
GIVE YOU KIND OF MY OLD AROUND.
BUT BACKGROUND ON THREE
INCREASES IN GENERAL AND I WILL
BE IN COURSES SHOULD BE ONLY
ENTERTAIN THE FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED.
DOES THE INCREASE ALL THROUGH
THE MISSION. DOESN'T TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT COST SAVINGS IS DONE IN
A CLASSROOM AT MANOR. WILL PUT
FROM STAKEHOLDERS. AND WE
SHOULD AGREE THAT CAN YOU FEEL
INCREASES SHOULD BE A RARE. THE
ONE THING THAT. WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT THE STAND EVERY DOC. IS
AND A SENIOR. COULD BE SEEN AS
A REQUEST. SO WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE WE TAKE THESE INCREASES
SERIOUSLY. THE OLDER DRESSES
HOW I WOULD PROCESS THEY
INCREASE THE NUMBER TWO WE TALK
ABOUT THE PUBLIC PARTY OR JUST
A PRETTY CERTAIN WE HAVE TO DO
A BETTER JOB. IT UP FORTUNATE
THAT I HAD. BEEN ON THE DISEASE
YOU SEE A FAMILY FOR TWELVE
YEARS OR BOARD OF PHARMACY. AND
THERE ARE JOB WHAT TO DO BOYS
TO THOSE PUBLIC MEMBERS WHO
DIDN'T HAVE A VOICE WE HAVE A
BOAT. BE HEARD AND LISTEN TO.
AND I WILL TAKE THAT SAME
PROCESS. WOULD BE TO THE
MEDICAL MORE. THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD MS COMPARED A- THANK YOU
IN ADDITION TO MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS ON THE FEE INCREASE
ACTUALLY WANT TO ADDRESS TWO
OTHER PIECES WHICH ARE THE FACT
THAT I AM HEARTENED BY THE FACT
THAT WE JUST SIGNED AN MOU WITH
EACH YOU WHY YOU IN ORDER TO
SHORTEN OUR TIME FRAMES AND
STREAMLINED OUR PROCESS AS FAR
AS INVESTIGATIONS BECAUSE
SENATOR TO YOUR POINT THERE SO
MANY DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME
THERE'S A FEET USE WHICH WE
HAVE INCREASED OUR FEET IN
FIFTEEN YEARS BUT I AM
CERTAINLY MINDFUL OF THE FACT
THAT THESE COSTS ARE ARE ARE
BURDENS ESPECIALLY ON DOCTORS
OF COLOR WHO MAY NOT. HAVE THE
SAME NEEDS AS THEIR COLLEAGUES
AND SO BEING ABLE TO STREAMLINE
OUR PROCESS AND ON THE OTHER
HAND AS WELL AS WILL INCREASE
OUR COMMUNICATION WITH THE
PUBLIC I THINK ALL THOSE THINGS
OPERATING IN TANDEM WILL DO
WHAT IT IS YOU'RE SAYING AND
START TO REESTABLISH TRUST AT
THE LEVEL OF THE PUBLIC
DESERVES AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL AS
MEDICAL OR TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE PUBLIC IN RIGHT WHERE THEY
ARE AND IN IN A CULTURALLY
COMPETENT WAY IN A WAY THAT
RESPECTS THE FACT THAT IT IS A
COMPLICATED PROCESS AND WE
SHOULD DO A BETTER JOB AT
EXPLAINING IT. SO THAT. PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S BEHIND THE
CURTAIN. THANK YOU. ALL AND-
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING-
YOUR APPOINTMENTS AND
APPRECIATE THE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR GROWTH. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM UM. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES IS
QUESTIONS- THE WERE SIMILAR IN
LINE TO WHAT I HAD TO ASK-
FIRST OF ALL WHEN WELCOME ALL
OF YOU TO THIS- CONFIRMATION
HEARING AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE ON THIS-
THE BOARD. AS I WANT TO GO BACK
TO THE ENFORCEMENT MODEL
HISTORICALLY USED- IT THE- THE
BOARD USED TO HAND OFF METHOD-
ENFORCEMENT MODEL SIMILAR TO.
OTHER ENTITIES WITH AS THE DCA
DEBT YOU KNOW DEPUTY ATTORNEY-
BUT THE DCA- THE HANDOFF MODEL
WAS- ADJUSTED TO A VERTICAL
MODEL I BELIEVE IS WHAT IT WAS
CALLED. FOR VERTICAL
ENFORCEMENT MODEL IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE- I THINK SB
TWO THIRTY ONE FIGARO WAS
REQUIRED THE BOARD TO IMPLEMENT
ALTERNATIVE MODELS TO. TO
MINIMIZE THE LENGTH OF TIME
INVESTIGATIONS WERE TAKING
PLACE I BELIEVE EVERYONE YOU
KNOW UP TO NINE HUNDRED DAYS
AND THE GOAL OF THE BOARD WAS
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY DAYS TO
RESOLVE CASES. SO- YOU KNOW.
WITH THE FAMILY- THAT HAD A
COMPLAINT OR A COMPLAINT WAS
ISSUED. AND THEY HAD TO WAIT
THREE YEARS ON A DECISION- I
THINK THAT'S WHERE. THE ISSUE
LIES WITH THE PUBLIC OPPOSITION.
IS THAT NOT HAVING THE PROCESS.
IN A MORE EXPEDITED FASHION BUT
I DO ALSO KNOW THAT THERE HAS
TO BE COMPLETE INVESTIGATIVE
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT- THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM YOU KNOW JUSTICE
IS THERE. AND THE COMPLETE
INVESTIGATION THE TRUTH CAN BE
TOLD. SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
THAT- FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND
I'M AND ADDRESSING IT TO DOCTOR
HAWKINS I GUESS BECAUSE HE'S
BEEN ON THE BOARD- BEORE OUR
ANY OTHER OF THE BOARD MEMBERS
THE DIRECTORS WOULD LIKE TO
READ A REPLY. AND THAT'S AS
WELL WELL I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
YOUR COMMENTS. FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE WHAT MEASURES IF
ANY CAN BE TAKEN TO STREAMLINE
OTHERWISE IMPROVE THE BOARD'S
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS BECAUSE
AGAIN. WE ARE BACK WITH SENATOR
HILLS BILL SB SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT- THAT STOP THE VERTICAL-
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS BECAUSE-OBVIOUSLY IT ADDED TIME TO THE
INVESTIGATION. SO WHAT DID ANY
OF YOU SEE IN THE FUTURE TO
MAKE. AT A SOME MORE
STREAMLINED PROCESS IN THE
INVESTIGATION PROCESS. SO THAT
PEOPLE THAT HAVE ISSUES OR
COMPLAINTS WITH THE BOARD WOULD
BE ABLE TO HAVE. RESOLUTION
QUICKER. I THINK ABOUT FAMILIES
THAT MAY HAVE HAD- AN
UNEXPECTED FATALITY LET'S JUST
SAY THAT AN UNEXPECTED TO
FATALITY OR AN UNEXPECTED
SITUATION. THAT CAUSED A MAJOR
MEDICAL ISSUE WITH A FAMILY
MEMBER OR LOVED ONE. AND THEY
CARRY THAT BURDEN AND THAT
FIGHT FOR THREE YEARS UNTIL THE
BOARD CAN RESOLVE- THE ISSUE SO
I GUESS MY CONCERN IS ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSTITUENTS THAT WE ALL
REPRESENT. IS THERE A
STREAMLINED PROCESS THAT ALL OF
YOU ARE- LOOKING AT. SO THAT.
IT CAN BE INVESTIGATED
THOROUGHLY. AND WE DON'T CUT
ANY CORNERS BUT THAT IT TAKES
LESS THAN THREE YEARS TO DO.
AND WHAT WE START WITH UGH AS
THE SENATOR INDICATED DR
HAWKINS AND THEN I WILL SEE WHO
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO ADD TO THAT
IF THAT IS OKAYYES DOCTOR
HAWKINS GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WOULD. BUSINESS
SAY THAT THE NUMBER SO
SATISFIED WITH SOME OF THOSE
TIME LINES FOR THE MOST EXTREME
CASES SUMMER. CLOSE SOONER BUT
WE'RE NOT SATISFIED WITH THREE
YEARS TAKES CLOSE A CASE. YOU
TOUCHED ON SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WILL GRAPPLE WITH ALL THE
TIME. THESE ARE COMPLICATED
CASES- THAT REQUIRE. DUE
PROCESS THE REQUIRE A HIGHER
LEVEL OF BURDEN OF PROOF-
ACTUALLY THE CLEAR AND
CONVINCING WHICH IS NOT THE
SAME AS SOME OF THESTATES FROM
WHICH THE STATISTICS CAME FROM.
THERE WERE TOLD ABOUT THAT THE
RAIDERS KINDA LOW AMONG THE-
THE- STATES IN TERMS OF MEDICAL
BOARDS- BUT- AND I DON'T WANT
TO MAKE IT SEEM THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO MAKE CHANGES WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE CHANGES IN. THIS
CONTROVERSY MENTIONED THE
MEMBER UNDERSTANDING WHERE. WE
HOPE TO STREAMLINE. THIS A
MEMBER UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN
DCA IS EXTRA YOU IT FOR YOUR
THE INVESTIGATIVE ARM BUT THE
BOARD- AND SHOULD WE SPEND 80%
OF OUR FUNDS UNDER FORCING. ON
PUBLIC PROTECTION FORCES- NEED
TO BE BALANCING THAT WITH- THE
COMMUNICATION INCLUSION WITH
PUBLIC- SO THESE CASES ARE
COMPLEX OFTEN TWIST ALONG THIS
ONE'S A COMPLEX SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT AND WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE CONTROLS YOU KNOW WE
DEPENDED ON- THE INVESTIGATOR-
WHO HAS TO INVESTIGATE A MORE
COMPLEX CASE WITH A HIGHER
BURDEN WE HAVE TO DEPEND ON.
OUR EXPERTS WHO TELL US OR THE
TELL THE INVESTIGATORS THE
TOURNEY GENERAL OFFICE SAID
THIS IS WHAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
PROVE THIS ASSEMBLY DEPARTURE
GROSS NEGLIGENCE STRICT
DEPARTURE AND THIS LIMITS WHAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO ALLEGE OR PROVE.
MMHM AND THOSE INTO. THE
GENERAL- ISSUE ARE YOU- THE-
OFFICES HEARINGS THEY ALL HAVE
THEIR OWN TIME LINES AS WELL SO
WE HOPE TO DRILL DOWN AND WITH
THE MINIMUM OF STANDING JOURNAL
DOWN ON THE THINGS THAT HELP US
SOLVE THESE LONGEST CASES. GET
THEM QUICKER. WE BELIEVE THAT
EARLY COMMUNICATION BETWEEN.
THE BOARD AND EXTRA YOU WILL BE
HELPFUL- ALTHOUGH VERTICALLY
FORCING. CHANGE AMERICAN FORCE
WAS EXPECTED TO IMPROVE THE
SITUATION ACTUALLY DID NOT. THE
IMAGE OF THE NUMERICAL
UNDERSTANDING. SOMETIMES WITH
DELAYED SLICKLY BY NOT GOING TO
GET MEDICAL RECORDS AND FINES
CAN BE IMPOSED TO GET THOSE
ALTHOUGH SOMETIMES A SURPRISE
SUBPOENA- WE TALKED ABOUT
WHETHER WE CAN GET. LEGISLATION
TO HELP- BISCUIT IS GOING TO
THE OFFICE OF LOOK AT RECORDS
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION WHETHER
ALLEGATION CAN BE MADE.
SOMETIMES WE DON'T GET. A
MEDICAL RECORD- THE RELEASE IS
BECAUSE THE PATIENT I WANTED TO
AFFORD TO RESTATE SHOES BUT WE
NEED THOSE MEDICAL RECORDS TO
DETERMINE. ANALYTICS SERVER
EVER IMPORTANT- I'M SUPPOSED TO
TALK ABOUT THAT IN ASKING
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS WE NEED TO
PROVIDE EXPERT POOL AND SOME BY
MEMBERS I TALKED ABOUT THE
SIZING THAT. WAS TO BE HONEST
BOOKED ABOUT A REALLY WANTED TO
HELP US WITH THAT WE RECOGNIZE
A EXPERTS. ACTUALLY INFLUENCE
HOW FAR WE OFTEN CAN GO THAT'S
NOT UNCOMMON FOR US TO HAVE
GOOD EXPERTS BUT TO HAVE. THE
POSITION AVERAGE WHAT IS
PERCEIVED AS AN EXODUS OF
PRIMITIVE- EXPERT. AND OF
COURSE THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION INTO RECORDATION
ABOUT COST RECOVERY. THE OPEN
INTO THE QUESTIONS IT'S
COMPLICATED. NO THIS IS NOT
SIMPLE WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE
HAVE TO DO A BETTER JOB WITH
THIS AND WE WILL. THANK YOU SIR
WOULD ANYONE ELSE SHOW ME YOUR
HAND IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT OR
ADD ON TO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO OKAY MISS LUCIANO GO RIGHT
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU IF I CAN
BUILD UP. ON DR HOPKINS
RESPONSE. SO I THINK- YOU KNOW.
ONE THING. THAT WE RECOGNIZED
AS YOU KNOW WE WEREN'T WE WERE
USING VERTICAL ENFORCEMENT.
THAT WASN'T WORKING. WE STOPPED
DOING THAT- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THE PROCESS NOW. AND THAT'S- IN
A LONGER THAT'S TAKING LONGER
THE- LOOKING AT AT AT THE TIME
WINSTON BEFORE. SO WE'RE AT A
POINT THAT. THOSE TWO METHODS
AREN'T WORKING SO WHAT IS THE
NEW METHOD AND SO. I THINK WE
ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT IT FROM
THAT BROAD PERSPECTIVE. AND
THAT TAKES. YOU KNOW THE- THE
WORK OF ME THAT INVOLVES NOT
JUST THE MEDICAL BOARD BUT ALSO.
THE AG'S. AND NDC TO SEE WELL
IS THERE A NEW PROCESS THAT
COULD PERHAPS SPEED THINGS UP-
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE WAY TO
LOOK AT IT ALSO DOT AS DOCTOR
HAWKINS MENTIONED. YOU KNOW
THERE THERE ARE OTHER OTHER
WAYS WE CAN ATTACK IT
ESPECIALLY WITH THE RECORDS-
YOU WE TALKED ABOUT THAT IN OUR
SENSE THAT REPORT THAT YOU KNOW
THAT COULD BE. AN EASY A FAST
FIX THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
HELP US YOU KNOW TO GIVE US
THOSE POWERS YOU KNOW AND
INVESTIGATORS HOURS TO GO IN.
AND GET GET FOR IT SPECIFICALLY
FOR EXAMPLE PHARMACY RECORDS IN
A IN A MUCH FASTER TIME. THAN
IT'S HAPPENING NOW THAT CAN
CERTAINLY. PETER EFFORTS- AND
THEN ALSO AS ALSO MENTION I IN
OUR SENSE THAT REPORT- YOU TO
HELP US BUILD ON THE TOOLKIT OF
RESPONSES- YOU WE GET. AS
YOU'VE SEEN IN OVER TEN
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS IN A YEAR
WHICH WE HAVE TO TRIAGE AND-
MOST OF THOSE ARE THANKFULLY
ARE- YOU KNOW THEY MAY BE MINOR
INFRACTIONS OR AT LAST YEAR
YES- CASES AND- IF WE HAVE
MORE. MATHIS IN OUR TOOL KIT TO
MORE SWIFTLY DISPOSABLES AND
HANDLE THOSE AND THAT SHOULD
SPEED UP THE TIMELINE OVERALL.
SAID JUST WANTED TO ADD A
LITTLE MORE COLOR. WITH THOSE
POINTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT I'D LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT AND WHAT CAN
WE DO TO HELP YOU GET SOME OF
THOSE TOOLS IN YOUR TOOLKIT WHY
CAN'T YOU DISPENSE OF THOSE
MINOR INFRACTIONS OF THE TEN
THOUSAND. IN A MORE EXPEDITED
FASHION SO THAT YOU CAN SPEND
TIME. ON THE MORE SERIOUS
INFRACTIONS THAT- ARE TAKING A
LONG LENGTH OF TIME TO BE ABLE
TO DISPOSE OF. MAKE A COMMENT.
ABSOLUTE HAWKINS. I'M SORRY
LAURIE BUT SPEAKER. WELL THE
THANK YOU- SO WHAT PEOPLE. I
TRAIN PEOPLE SO I THINK THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FOREIGN
INVESTORS H. O. U. OFFERS
CERTAIN SKILL SET BY THEY ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T REQUIRE
THAT SKILL SET THAT ONCE
TRAINED CAN ACTUALLY HANDLE
SOME OF THOSE CASES THAT DON'T
REQUIRE. AN ALLEGATION OR OR
THIS A PUBLIC HARM. IN A RATHER-
THAT'S GOING TO GO FURTHER IN
THE IN THE IN THE ENFORCEMENT
ARENA SO MORE STAFF. IT CAN BE-
HELPFUL AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT TO GET A GOOD
BALANCE OF WHAT THE KIND OF
NUMBERS YOU NEED TO ADDRESS.
THE FLOW AND LOCAL I'M IN THE
CENTER COMPLAIN UNIT- THE- AND
I THINK I'D MENTIONED AND MR
THE BILL ALSO TOUCHED ON THE
IDEA ABOUT- SO APPROACH TO
MEDICAL RECORDS AND-
LEGISLATION PUTTING A DO HONOR
THAT REVISIT THAT YOURSELF. YES
SO FOR EXAMPLE WITH RESPECT TO
PHARMACY RECORDS THAT GOES TO-
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
FORTY EIGHTY ONE AND THAT TALKS
ABOUT THE PHARMACY HAVING TO
PROVIDE THE RECORDS IN A QUOTE
UNQUOTE REASONABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME. AND SO REASONABLE TO THE
PHARMACY COULD BE YOU KNOW
EIGHT MONTHS PERHAPS BUT TO THE
COMPLAINANT- AND TO US WE'RE
TRYING TO PROCESS THESE AND GET
THROUGH THE FASTER IT
REASONABLE TO LESS IS MORE LIKE
TWO WEEKS OR THIRTY OR THIRTY
DAYS OR FOR EXAMPLE SO. THAT
YOU KNOW THAT COULD BE
SOMEWHERE WHERE LEGISLATION
COULD COME IN TO HELP US SPEED
UP BUT UP A TIMELY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH M. I KNOW ALL OF YOU
I'M SURE ALL OF YOU ARE VERY
SOLUTION ORIENTATED TO SOLVE
SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS BUT I
SPECIFICALLY. APPRECIATE AND
MISLI BEYOND- AND I MISTER
HOPKINS YOUR COMMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT. AND YOU'RE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH IT- IF IT-
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL- IN THE
AG'S OFFICE AND TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS AND THEN FEED GIVE US
FEEDBACK AS THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THAT SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY
SIMPLE SOLUTION I MEAN WHY
CAN'T WE GO IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FROM REASONABLE
TIME TO THIRTY DAYS TO PULL A
RECORD. AND GET BACK TO YOU
WHICH WOULD HELP EXPEDITE IT
AND THE PROCESS AND HELP YOU
GUYS. AND BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO
THE COMMUNITY SO TANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS BUT I AM GOING
TO MAKE A COMMENT AND- MR
BEYOND- I JUST- NOT TO BELABOR
THE POINT NINETY SEVENTY SIX
BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I
TO- AS A MOM AND A GRANDMA. I
THINK MOTHERS IN INITIAL
INSTINCT IS A LIKE A LIONESS
RIGHT PROTECT YOUR PET PROTECT
YOUR CHILDREN. AND I TO LOOKED
IN THE EYES OF THOUSANDS OF
PARENTS DURING THAT PROCESS
THEY TRULY BELIEVE IN FELT FROM
THE BOTTOM OF THEIR HEART AND
HAD MEDICAL EVIDENCE TO SHOW
THAT. THEY FELT THAT TO AND
THEIR CHILD THAT WAS QUOTE
UNQUOTE NORMAL BEFORE CERTAIN
VACCINES AND THEN BECAME EITHER
AND LEGS ATROPHIED OR HAD
ISSUES THEM. OCULAR
DEGENERATION AND OTHERS- THAT
WERE PROMINENT AND- AND THE
FEAR OF NOT VACCINE ARE YOU
KNOW NOT VACCINATING THEIR
SECOND OR THIRD CHILD- FOR FEAR
OF A FAMILY ISSUE. AND I
REMEMBER THOSE DAYS I MEAN THE
SENATE PRO TEM AND I'M SURE
BOTH REMEMBER THOSE DAYS
BECAUSE THEY WERE ACTIVELY IN
THE BUILDING. BUT M. SO I
SYMPATHIZE WITH YOU HAVING A
CONCERN. ABOUT A PARENT'S
CONCERN FOR THEIR CHILD SO- I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR THAT
AS WELL ND I'VE NEVER
QUESTIONS MA'AM PROTECT. THANK
YOU SENATOR. GROVE MAN OF ICE
HERE. THANK YOU. AND- CAN TO
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR-
APPOINTMENTS I DON'T. SKEWS ME
MY ALLERGIES WITH THESE MASKS
ANYWAY- I LOOKED AT YOUR
RESUMES OUR THIRTY DAM IN DOUBT
I DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO MEET
WITH YOU INDIVIDUALLY BUT AS I
READ THOSE I THOUGHT WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE STEPPED FORWARD TO
SERVE ON THE MEDICAL BOARD AND
CERTAINLY ARE HI FIVE TO DOCTOR
HAWKINS WHO'S BEEN THERE FOR A-
WHAT IS IT NOW ABOUT SEVEN
YEARS SIX AND A HALF YEARS AND-
IT IS A VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO
FIND AND WE ALL KNOW THAT I AM
ON THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS. COMMITTEE AND WE
DID THE SUNSET REVIEW OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD IT WAS VERY CLEAR
THAT MOST OF THE ISSUES WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD ARE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE. CERTAINLY OUT OF
YOUR INDIVIDUAL CONTROL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR DISCUSSION WITH A
GOOD SENATOR MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ON BECAUSE-
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE A- DEEPER AND LONGER LOOK
AT IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
RESOLVE. I THINK THE DEFICIT
THAT ARE THERE ARE THE COSTS
THAT WERE SHARED WITH US. FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
OPERATING ABOARD IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX SEVEN. IT IS
MUSHROOM TO FIFTEEN. AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS- THIS LAST
FISCAL YEAR TO EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AND YOU'RE
NOT ALONE IN TERMS OF THAT KIND
OF COST OF THE WORK THAT YOU
DO. BECAUSE DURING THAT SUNSET
REVIEW IT APPEARED TO BE THE
COSTS THAT. DO COME FORWARD THE
INVESTIGATION SAW. WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THEY WILL
BE PROVIDING A FROM. FROM I
THINK A PATH WHERE WE CAN FIND
A BALANCE HERE OF FOR ALL THE
BOARDS BUT IN PARTICULAR THIS
ONE. BECAUSE I THINK THE GOALS
THAT YOU SET FORTH. IN YOUR
PRESENTATION. YEAH COTTON FELL
I WAS IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE
TRUST THE TRANSPARENCY ON
CERTAINLY ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR
THOSE WHO COME BEFORE THE BOARD
WITH THEIR COMPLAINTS. SO I
THINK THE ONLY THING LEFT OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT I'M ALREADY
BEEN ANSWERED IN QUITE A JOB.
WOULD BE THE COMPLAINT PROCESS
FILE IN OUR LAST REVIEW OF
MEDICAL BOARD MEMBERS THERE WAS
A CONCERN THAT COMPLAINT TENTH
CAN'T TRACK. OF THE PROGRESS OF
THEIR COMPLAINT I THINK THAT
GOES A LONG WAY IN TERMS OF IF
THERE'S A SYSTEM I KNOW YOU'RE
WORKING ON IT I BELIEVE THAT
WITH THE INFORMATION PROVIDED.
I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S UP AND
RUNNING BUT CLEAR CLEARLY THAT
WILL HELP A LOT BECAUSE WHEN
PEOPLE. ARE NOT IN THE KNOW AND
THEY'RE FRUSTRATED THAT'S WHEN
ALL OF THE- ANGST DEVELOPED AND
THEN IT BECOMES ANGRY AND THEN
IT BECOMES AN OUTRAGE THAT. YOU
KNOW YOU'RE NOT DOING YOUR JOB
AND IF SO MANY OF THE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT VERY COMPLEX
JOB THAT YOU DO HAVE. WITH OUR
MEDICAL PROFESSION AND WE HA HA
HOLD ALL OF THEM IN HIGH
REGARD. SOME NOT FROM YOU KNOW
WANDER OFF THE PATH AND FIND
THEMSELVES. YOU KNOW
COMPLAINING BEING INVESTIGATED
BUT THAT THAT IS YOUR JOB BUT
WE DO NEED TO ADD TO KNOW. IF
YOU'VE MOVED ALONG ON THAT
COMPLAINT PROCESS IF THERE IS A
LOT OF ATTENTION TO THAT SO
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE- YOU KNOW.
COMPLETING ARE NOT FIGHTING
PARTICULAR SITUATIONS ARE THAT
RISE TO A COMPLAINT AND
INVESTIGATION HOW THEY'RE
NOTIFIED. AND IF YOU HAVE
SOMETHING THAT'S EASILY
ACCESSIBLE FOR THEM WE'RE
WORKING TOWARDS THAT AND I
GUESS DR HAWK AND SHE'S. BEEN
THERE THE LONGEST AND PROBABLY
BEEN INVOLVED WITH THAT YOU.
MIGHT WANT TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION DIRECTLY. YES SIR ALL.
IN IN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
KNOWLEDGE OF IT- IT'S BEEN.
YEARS ON THE- AND- IT'S A
DIFFICULT BOARD THE- THERE
CHALLENGES IT'S A VERY VERY
VERY IMPORTANT BOARD THAT
SPENDING IN A DOLLAR EACH. ONE
OF THE THINGS INDIVIDUAL BEING
REPETITIVE NOW IS THAT WE NEED
AND WILL BE MORE RESPONSIVE- TO
THE CONSUMERS ARE STAKEHOLDERS
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THEY'RE NOT
BEING SEEN AND HEARD IN A WAY
THAT THEY WANT TO BE AND
DESERVE TO BE. AND WE HAVE SOME
FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE CALL NOW
MR LOOK BEYOND DISCOVERED
THEY'RE BOTH AND MYSELF FOR ALL
ON THIS. UNDERGROUND REACH-
COMMUNICATION AND- WELLNESS
COMMITTEE AND YOU HEARD FROM
THE DISCUSSIONS THE SKILLS THAT
THEY- BRING. TO THIS PROBLEM.
DAHLE SAID SOME DISCUSSIONS
WITH SOME OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
CENTER FOR PUBLIC OUTREACH.
SENATE REPUBLICAN LAW AND DIEGO
DURING WITH THEM TO HELL US.
HELLO WITH THE CONSUMERS AND SO
OF FOR HAVE BEEN ALSO. TO DO A
BETTER- AT THE PRESENT TIME THE
NEW SYSTEM THIS IS NOT A
SUBSTITUTE FOR PORTAL BACK THAT
IS SET UP- IN A WAY SECURELY
THAT THE COMPLAINING CAN
ACTUALLY TRACK WHERE. THE
INVESTIGATION IS IN THEIR
ALLEGATION THAT'S WHAT WE WANT
TOGET- AND WE'RE GETTING THERE
BUT I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT TIME
FOR WHATEVER OCCURRED. WHAT
SHOULD BE HAPPENING IS THAT-
THE COMPLAINT IT SHOULD BE
GETTING A PAPER. EMAIL THEY CAN
KNOWLEDGE AND IF THEY'RE CASES
CLOSE OF HIS MOVES TO THE NEXT
LEVEL DOES NOT GIVE ENOUGH
DETAIL- BUT THAT'S CLOSELY
HAVING ALREADY- AND- I AFTER
TALKING TO THE C. THE CHAIR OF
THE- FEDERAL PLAY UNIT I WANT
TO CONFIRM THAT THAT IS IN FACT
HAPPENING. BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME COMMENTS ABOUT THAT FROM
THE PUBLIC- SO WE'RE WORKING ON
PRIORITY. AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE WILL WILL SOLVE THAT BUT
IT'S IT IS CHALLENGING BECAUSE
OF THINGS LIKE CONFIDENTIALITY.
I HOPE THAT'S HELPFUL. HELPFUL
AND- PLEASE CALL AN ALPHA FOR
WHAT WE MIGHT DO TO ASSIST YOU
IN IN ON YOUR GOALS AND
CERTAINLY THE OBJECTIVES THAT
MUST BE THERE TO ACCOMPLISH
THOSE GOALS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE FITS
SANDERS HELPING WITH THOSE- YOU
KNOW ACTUAL- PROPHECIES
REGULATIONS WHATEVER. THAT WILL
ASSIST YOU GETTING TO A WHERE
ARE OUR MEDICAL BOARD IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST REGARD. THROUGHOUT THE
NATION AND I KNOW YOU WANT THAT
WE CERTAINLY WANT THAT AND
CERTAINLY FOR OUR
CONSTITUENCIES YOU HAVE DOWN WE
HAVE THEM AND WE SHARE THEM AS
A MATTER OF FACT IS WHAT WE
WANT TO PROVIDE THEM SO THANK
YOU AND DOC. I WILL PASS THE
MICROPHONE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES I HEAR I THINK THERE
MIGHT BE SOME THINGS LEFT THAT
NEEDS. OUR DISCUSSION ALSO BUT
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND ALL I DO BELIEVE
OUT IF IT'S A REALLY- VERY GOOD
GROUP PUBLIC MEMBERS DOCTORS ON
THERE THAT GIVE THAT DIVERSITY-
FOR A PERSPECTIVE THAT I THINK
IS SO IMPORTANT. FOR ANYBODY
WHO'S HAD AN ISSUE WITH THEIR
VISION OR THEIR HEALTHCARE.
PROVIDER THANK YOU. Q. ADVISED-
SENATOR LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM. AND I. THE MEETING
WITH ALL FOR OF YOU YESTERDAY.
AND THE DESPITE WHAT DOES
SENATOR BATES SAID THERE IS NOT
MUCH THAT HASN'T BEEN TALKED
ABOUT YET- AND I DECIDED. SINCE
IT'S ALWAYS DIFFICULT WHEN WE
HAVE FOUR FIVE TOGETHER AND
EVERYBODY WANTS TO RESPOND THIS
TIME I DECIDED BASED ON OUR
MEETING I WAS GONNA WRITE
SOMETHING THAT EACH OF YOU SAID
AND ASK YOU ABOUT IT FOLLOW UP
INDIVIDUALLY AND THUS FAR.
EVERY SINGLE ONE HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED WHETHER IT'S- THE IT
WAS- MISTER BROOKS SAYING YOU
CAN'T FIX WHAT YOU CAN'T
MEASURE- FOR- DOCTOR HAWKINS
NOT SATISFIED WITH THE BACKLOG
OF CASES AND SAYING. THE PUBLIC
IS TALKING BUT WERE NOT
RESPONDING FOR MISS CAR WILL BE
ON TALKING ABOUT TIME LINES.
AND I THOUGHT THAT JUST DO ONE
THING AND THAT IS THAT. THIS
HEARING IS NOTABLY DIFFERENT
FROM THE OTHER ONE WE HAD ON
THE MEDICAL BOARD AND I HAVE
ASSESSED. THE THAT IS DUE TO
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE MOSTLY
PUBLIC MEMBERS ED AND- OUR OF
REPRESENT THE PUBLIC. TO THE
BOARD IN A WAY THAT THAT IT
JUST DIDN'T HAVE THE LEVEL OF
INTENSITY THAT OUR PREVIOUS
HEARING AND SO THE ONE THING
IS. I WAS STRUCK BY A MIS COMPA
VERDES. PERSONAL STORY AND IT
CAME UP IN OUR A MEETING AND
YOU BROUGHT IT UP BRIEFLY. IN
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT BUT YOU
EVEN PRODUCED A DOCUMENTARY
FILM CALLED INHERITANCE ABOUT
YOUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT
YOU ALLUDED TO. AND I THOUGHT
IT MIGHT BE REALLY IMPORTANT IN
MAKING THAT POINT ABOUT HOW
PUBLIC MEMBERS ARE INFORMED BY
THEIR OWN EXPERIENCE AND BRING
THAT TO THIS IN A DIFFERENT
WIFE THAT. THAT MAYBE YOU TALK
ABOUT. WHAT YOU DID IN THAT
FILM. S. N. AND YOUR PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND HOW IT INFORMS
YOU BEING. ON THE MEDICAL BOARD
I THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO EVERYONE IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND. I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION SENATOR AND- AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW WE IT WOULD SERVICE TO
TALK ABOUT THAT AND THAT THE
PIECE OF IT AS MEMBERS OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD IN THE FILM THE
IDEA BEHIND IT AND IT KIND OF
CAME TOGETHER AS I WAS GOING
THROUGH MY OWN SURGICAL JOURNEY
THE IDEA BEHIND IT WAS TO
REALLY SHOW THE NEW WANTS TO
THE REALITY OF WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE TO TRY TO SAVE YOUR OWN
LIFE. AND A LOT OF WAYS THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ALL DOING WHEN WE
ENGAGE WITH THE MEDICAL SYSTEM
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO SAVE OUR
OWN LIVES WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
MAKE THE BEST DECISIONS WE
CAN'T AND ELONGATE OUR LIVES
AND THOSE OF OUR LOVED ONES AND
SO WATCHING WOMEN GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS IN MY FILM AND THE
HARD HARD CHOICES THEY'VE HAD
TO MAKE AND THE MODEL CHOICES
THEY'VE HAD TO MAKE WAS
SOMETHING THAT IS YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S ROCK ARE NO MATTER
WHAT. ILLNESS OR DISEASE
SOMEONE HAS TO DEAL WITH THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
UNIVERSALLY SHARE AND SO I
BRING THAT PERSPECTIVE TO EVERY
CONVERSATION EVERY MEETING THAT
I HAVE AROUND THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND I KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUES
AND I ARE TRYING TO PUT
OURSELVES IN THE SHOES OF YOU
KNOW THESE AREN'T THIS CASE
NUMBERS THESE ARE JUST
COMPLAINTS THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN HURT AND WHO ARE
HURTING AND SO HOW CAN WE-
BRING THAT EMPATHY AND RESPECT.
TO THE WAY WE COMPORT OURSELVES
AND ALWAYS HAVE THAT IDEA BE
THE GUIDING LIGHT OF THE BOARD
THERE'S A LOT TO BE DONE
CERTAINLY BUT THAT HAS TO BE AT
THE CORE OF WHAT WE DO IF YOU
ARE ABLE TO REALLY MAKE MEET.
OUR MISSION OF PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC. THANK YOU ON IT'S NOT A
EASY TO TOW. YOUR OWN STORY
IT'S GOING TO BE A PLEASURE TO
VOTE FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYERED AND- I'M
GLAD YOU. ACTUALLY DID THAT I
WAS MOVED AND COMPELLED BY YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS ALSO. HAS COME
A VERDE AND THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT. I DO ACTUALLY
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THAT
I WANT TO SET SOME CONTEXT-
CONFIRMATIONS BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ARE REALLY THE
WAY THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO OUR CONSTITUENTS-
AND I THINK- AS SENATOR LAYERED
ALLUDED TO. OUR INTRODUCTION
WAS THE CONFIRMATION HEARING OF
THREE OF THE- PHYSICIAN MEMBERS
OF THE BOARD. AND IT WAS- IT
WAS A ROUGH HEARING ACTUALLY
FOR US AND WE MOVE THOSE
CONFEREES TO THE FLOOR AND THEY
HAVE SINCE BEEN CONFIRMED.
SINCE THEN WE'VE ALSO HAD THE
ABILITY AS MY COLLEAGUES- VICE
CHAIRWOMAN SAID- IT TO WITNESS
AND WATCH SOME OF THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS IT'S TAKING
PLACE WITH THE BUSINESSES AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. AND I
THINK THAT GETS BACK TO THE
COMMENT THAT MS COM LONGER
MADE- HER TECHNICAL TERM WAS
HOT MESS UP BUT I THINK. REALLY
HOW I WOULD REDIRECT THAT
STATEMENT IS I LISTEN TO THE
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS. AND IT
WAS CLEAR TO ME AFTER HAVING
HEARD FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO EXPRESSED THEIR
CONCERN THAT THE BOARD WAS NOT
EXACTLY. FULLY ENGAGED IN THE
PUBLIC PROTECTION PIECE OF AND
THAT WAS THEIR CONCERN AND WE
HEARD THAT AT OUR LAST HEARING.
IT WAS UNCLEAR TO ME WHETHER
THROUGH THE ATTORNEY OF THE
BOARD. THE EXECUTIVE OF THE
BOARD. AND THERE WAS AT LEAST
ONE BOARD MEMBER MAYBE TO THAT
SPOKE THAT THERE'S ON CLARITY
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS AND HOW
MANY CASES ARE HANDLED AND WHAT
THE DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS ARE-
AND THAT WAS REALLY TROUBLING
TO ME IN THE SHORT TIME THAT I
LISTENED MANNER VICE CHAIRWOMAN
YOU WERE ON THE COMMITTEE. AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY- I REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INABILITY
OF- THROUGH THAT PROCESS TO GET
A SENSE. OF THERE'S A LARGE
VOLUME OF CASES THAT'S VERY
CLEAR TEN THOUSAND AND THEN YOU
AS MISS LUCIANO SAYS. YOU WANT
TO YOU WANT IT YOU WANT TO
EFFICIENTLY AND QUICKLY DEAL
WITH THE MORE MINOR. NOT MINOR
IN THE MINDS OF PEOPLE WHO
COMPLAIN BUT THE MORE- LESS
EGREGIOUS SO THAT YOU CAN SPEND
THE TIME ON THE MORE DIFFICULT
CASES- WHAT WHAT CAME TO OUR
ATTENTION AND WE REALLY HAVE NO
WAY TO GAUGE THIS AS
LEGISLATORS IS THAT. WHEN
REVIEWING CASES THERE ARE
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH
THE INFORMATION THAT OUR STAFF
HAVE PROVIDED US THAT THERE ARE
TWO PANELS. EACH OF YOU SERVE
ON ONE OF THOSE PANELS. TO
REVIEW CASES APPLY DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES AND THAT THERE SEEM
TO BE SOME QUESTION AS TO
WHETHER THERE'S A DEVIATION
FROM THOSE GUIDELINES- AND TO
THE AMOUNT OF ABILITY TO
DEVIATE GOD. THAT MAY BE GIVE
LAW- PENALTIES- ON SOME OF THE
MORE EGREGIOUS CASES SO I
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK I WAS
RESOLVED. IN LISTENING TO THE
SUNSET REVIEW HEARING- THAT
THERE WAS AGREEMENT AND YOU AS
BOARD MEMBERS. I HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO I THINK
UNDERSTAND THOSE NUMBERS AND TO
UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE PUBLIC WHO. MAYBE HAS LOST
TRUST OR HAS SOME CONCERN. THAT
IS WHAT I WANT TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION. THAT CONCERNS ME- I
DO BELIEVE THAT- THAT THE VALUE
OF THE PUBLIC ROLE AND THE
VALUE OF THE DOCTORS WHO SERVE
ON THIS BOARD ARE BOTH
IMPORTANT AND VALUABLE I
BELIEVE IT IS THE TWO TOGETHER.
THAT REALLY PRODUCE THE PRODUCT
THAT CAN MAKE THE PUBLIC FEEL
COMFORTABLE- AND SO I THINK%
BOTH HAVE VALUE HAVEN'T KIND OF
SAID THAT STAGE THE BOARD HAS
TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF THE
FEE INCREASE BECAUSE THERE IS
INSOLVENCY IS AN ISSUE THERE'S
THE COST FACTOR AND OBVIOUSLY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THE
COSTS THAT HAVE GONE UP THERE-
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING YOU GET
TO CONTROL DIRECTLY. YOU HAVE
TO REACT TO IT- SO WITH THOSE
THINGS IN MIND THE THREE
PHYSICIANS THAT WE TALKED TO AT
OUR LAST ARE. HEARING ALL WAIT
N. R. AND GAVE US
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW TO DEAL
WITH THE INSOLVENCY ISSUE. NOT
JUST IN TERMS OF THE FEE
INCREASE THAT MIGHT HAVE TO BE
CONSIDEREDAN AT WHAT LEVEL ON
THE BALANCE OF THAT DEBT.
CENTER COME LONGER BROUGHT UP
IN DOCTOR HAWKINS RESPONDED TO-
WOOD I A FROM EACH OF YOU. AND
THEY SAID IN THEIR LETTER OF
RESPONSE TO US EACH OF THOSE
POSITIONS THAT COST RECOVERY
WAS ALSO A FACTOR BEING
CONSIDERED BY THE BOARD. SO I
WILL START WITH YOU- DOCTOR
HAWKINS AND ASK IS COST
RECOVERY. SOMETHING THAT THE
BOARD IS LOOKING AT AND
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER TO BE ONE TOOL IN THE
TOOL KIT TO. MANAGE COSTS BUT
ALSO HOPEFULLY BE ONE OF THE
TOOLS TO HELP SHORTEN THE
PROCESS OF THE INVESTIGATIVE.
PIECE OF WHAT YOU'RE DEALING
WITH. YES IT CERTAINLY IS AND I
WOULD. INDICATE WHEN I HAD
MEETINGS WITH THE CASTRO OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE SHE
REASSURED ME THAT CASACORNELIA
ABOUT THE BOARD'S ACTUALLY DOES
WORK. IS IT DOES HELP
ACCOMPLISH YOUR CAN HELP
ACCOMPLISH THE THINGS LIKE THE-
THE TIME IT TAKES TO CLOSE
CASES THE WILLINGNESS OF.
PHYSICIANS TO. ENGAGE
ACCEPTABLE STIPULATED
SETTLEMENTS ARE OFFERED XCERRA
SO YES WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS
AND YES IT NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED I'M MIXED ON THE
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT BOARD AND
THEY HAVE COST RECOVERY. AND
THEY ASSURED ME THAT HAS AN
IMPACT ON WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THANK YOU DR MISSILE
BEYOND NO COST RECOVERY IS THAT
A TOOL POTENTIALLY IN THE TOOL
KIT TO HELP WITH SOME OF THE
COMPLEX ISSUES AND RESOLUTION
OF CASES. YES ABSOLUTELY I
THINK THAT WOULD- THAT WOULD
DEFINITELY HELP LEVEL THE
PLAYING IN THE PLAYING FIELD.
WITH THEIR CASES BECAUSE YOU
KNOW. AS OUR FINANCIAL
SITUATION HAS PUT US- HAS IT
HAS PUT US IN THE IN THE PLACE
WHERE IT COSTS IS TOP OF MIND
WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW
FAR TO PUSH A CASE THROUGH.
THIRD SO DEFINITELY YES THANK
YOU MISS CONTRAVIR DAY YOUR
THOUGHTS ON COST RECOVERY IS AN
OPTION. YES I SUPPORTED IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE'RE ONE OF
THE FEW IF NOT THE ONLY DISABLE
OR WHO DOES NOT HAVE COST
RECOVERY FOR- OUR DOCTORS AND
SO I DO SUPPORT THAT. THANK YOU
AND MISTER BROOKS I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVEN'T YET HAD A CHANCE TO
ATTEND A MEETING BUT GIVEN.
YOUR HISTORY OBVIOUSLY YOU
HAVE- YOU HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF
THIS FROM YOUR SERVICE ALREADY
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU THINK
THIS BOARD SHOULD CONSIDER.
WHAT THEY CONSIDER 1100% YOU
KNOW ON THE BOARD OF PHARMACY
WE DO HAVE COST RECOVERY. AND
IT'S DONE IN A COUPLE DIFFERENT%
WAYS ONE STIPULATED DECISIONS
EVERY STIPULATED DECISION HAS
TO HAVE A FINANCIAL COMPONENT
TO IT. BUT IN ORDER FOR THAT
STIPULATED DECISION TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED IN SOCCER WHEN WE
LOOK AT. LICENSING THE
REINSTATING A- DOCTOR YOU KNOW.
THAT REINSTATEMENT SAYS WE HAVE
TO PAY- PENALTIES FEES AND THE
COST OF THE BEST FISH BEFORE
WILL REINSTATE SURE TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE LIGHTS. I DO
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSES. THE OTHER ON THE
OTHER QUICK I ANSWER- AND SORRY
FOR MY CONTEXT I THINK IT LENDS
TO. OUR DESIRE TO SEE YOU BE
ABLE TO DO THIS VERY DIFFICULT
JOB THAT YOU'RE DOING WITH SOME
MEASURE OF SUPPORT BUT BUT ALSO
THE PUBLIC TRUST. THERE HAS
BEEN A WE RECEIVED A LETTER
AFTER OUR LAST HEARING FROM- A
CUT US A COUPLE OF STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS. THAT BASICALLY SAID
THEY THINK THERE SHOULD BE-
MORE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION ON
THE BOARD RIGHT NOW I THINK IT
IS- EIGHT OUR MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS MEDICAL DOCTOR
APPOINTMENTS VARIOUS
CATEGORIES. PHYSICIAN FACULTY
PHYSICIAN- AND THEN MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THERE ARE EIGHT.
PHYSICIAN AND SEVEN OUR PUBLIC
MEMBERS- DO YOU THINK THE BOARD
COULD BE SERVED BY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION CERTAINLY
AGAIN NOT TAKEN AWAY FROM THE
VALUE WHICH IS. EVIDENT OF THE
PHYSICIAN MEMBERS- MS LIBBY I
LET ME ASK YOU THAT MORE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION ON THIS BOARD. AS
AN OPTION. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK YES WE CAN OKAY GREAT- MY
POSITION ON THIS IS IF THAT'S
WHAT IT TAKES IF THAT'S ONE ONE
AVENUE WHERE THE PUBLIC FEELS
MORE REPRESENTED- ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU. IS CONTRAVIR DAY
YOUR THOUGHTS ON ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. I WOULD
SUPPORTADDITIONAL PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION I ALSO DO WANT TO
ADD THAT I THINK IT ULTIMATELY
COMES DOWN TO THE INTEGRITY OF
THE INDIVIDUAL- VERSUS A
PHYSICIAN VERSUS PUBLIC MEMBER-
AND EQUITATION BUT I CERTAINLY
WOULD SUPPORT MARKED UP WITH
MEMBERS. THANK YOU MISTER
BROOKS. WILL NOT HAVE TO A
BOARD MEETING SO I'M NOT QUITE
SURE THE FOR CONTENT RIGHT. IF
THAT'S A FAIR STATEMENT THAT'S
A VERY FAIR STATEMENT. AS A
PUBLIC MEMBER ON THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY- THE DALLAS WAS ALWAYS
IMPORTANT AND BUILDING TRUST
WAS ALWAYS IMPORTANT. TO BUILD
THE TRUST FACTOR AND LOCAL
BORDER IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE IN SOME OF THESE
ARE CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
FACING NOTED- WHAT'S AND SELF
OUT. MISTER BROOKS- FORGIVE ME
I SHOULD ALWAYS KNOW THIS I
GUESS BUT WHAT WAS THE
BREAKDOWN ON THE PHARMACY BOARD
PUBLIC VERSUS- DO YOU REMEMBER
AND YOU. DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
COUNT FROM. OKAY DR HAWKINS.
THANK YOU- I'M NOT OPPOSED TO
ADDITION OTHER MEMBERS THAT I
WOULD ECHO WITH THIS
CONTROVERSY IS STATED AT THAT.
WE ALL BRING OUR LIFE'S
EXPERIENCE TRAINING. TO THE
TABLE AND WE USE THAT TO HELP
US DECIDE WHAT WE GONNA DO IN A
PARTICULAR SITUATION. FOR
EXAMPLE I'M A CONSUMER
ADVOCATE. THE MEDICAL FOR BUT-
MY PRIVATE PRACTICE. HAS WE
NATURALLY FLOWING FROM MY-
THERE WHICH ARE TO THE AS WELL-
WE HAVE A ACTIVE DIALOGUE- THIS
EXAMPLE. IS WILL BE ON OUR ON
THE SAME. AND SO WITH A GOOD
EXTRA. WE HAVE BECAUSE HAVE TO
HAVE BOTH. THE PUBLIC AND-
PHYSICIAN ASSISTED MEMBERS BUT
I WE HAVE TO BE VERY AND
DELIVER. ABOUT WHO'S
RECOMMENDED. AND WHO IS.
APPROVED TO MAKE SURE ID ONE
THAT THE PERSONS PEOPLE REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE MISSION OF THE
PORT. THAT THEY'RE WILLING TO.
PUT THAT FIRST AND PARAMOUNT
AND THAT THEY'RE WILLING TO
LEARN- FROM THE EXPERIENCES THE
BOARDS TO HAVE MAKE IT
BEARABLE. AND I'VE BEEN THAT
CAN HAPPEN WITH PUBLIC OR NON
PUBLIC I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE.
THE PUBLIC MEMBERS- AND I
APPRECIATE THE PHYSICIAN
MEMBERS AND ARMY THE HEDGE TO
MUCH EXCEPT IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO TRY TO GET A
FEELING FOR THE CHARACTER. THE
HELLO CHRIS WHO THE PERSON
WANTS TO PROVIDE SERVICE WITH
THEIR EXPERIENCE AND SHOWING
THAT IN THE PAST. THESE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT A
SELECTION. ROSS'S THANK YOU
WELL DOCTOR HAWKINS I THINK
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT I THINK
I TO THE POINT OF YOUR CONCERNS
EACH OF YOU HAVE EXPRESSED THIS
CONCERNS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND
THE TRUST OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
WORK THAT YOU DO ON THEIR
BEHALF ON THIS BOARD- I THINK
YOUR POINT IS VERY WELL TAKEN
AND I THINK THE PUBLIC. WHO
BASICALLY SAYS THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
THAT'S THE LENS THROUGH WHICH
THEY PUT THEIR CONCERNS AND
THAT IS THE SOLUTION THEY COME
UP WITH TO MAKE THE SITUATION
BETTER UT I THINK YOUR
RESPONSE WAS POINT ON POINT
ABSOLUTELY BOTH YOURS AND- MISS
COBB OF VERDES IN TERMS OF THE
COMMITMENT THAT THE BOARD
MEMBER. SO THANK YOU FOR THAT-
I WANT TO THANK EACH OF YOU-
CLEARLY- YOU KNOW THIS IS A
DIFFICULT JOB AND IT IS ONE
THAT YOU'RE DEDICATED TO AND SO
MUCH TO THE POINT THAT YOU- THE
CITY THROUGH THE PROCESS WHERE
YOU GET TO HEAR ARE HOW PEOPLE
FEEL ABOUT. HOW THE BOARD
REPRESENTS THEM I WOULD SAY AND
ASK. THAT YOU GIVE SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION TO- TO LOOKING AT
THE NUMBERS ARE EVALUATING A
LITTLE MORE- IN DETAIL WHETHER
THE GUIDELINES ARE BEING
FOLLOWED TO THE DEGREE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FEEL
LIKE- OF THE ACTION THAT IS
NECESSARY NECESSARY FROM THESE
PANELS AND THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCEEDING- THAT IT SEEMS THAT
THAT WORK IS BEING DONE AND
THOSE THAT DESERVE THE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION THAT'S
ACTUALLY WHAT IS HAPPENING.
THAT THE GUIDELINES ARE NOT.
ODD IS THAT THE GUIDELINES ARE
BEING FOLLOWED TO THE DEGREE
THAT THAT WORK IS DONE BECAUSE
I THINK THAT'S PART OF WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC BUT- TO YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR. SERVICE AND
YOUR TIME TODAY. I WE WILL- GO
AHEAD AND GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. AND WE WILL START RIGHT
HERE OF OUR FOLKS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE AND FOR THE
PUBLIC'S BENEFIT- I'M GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND SEE IF WE CAN POST
THE NUMBER AND I WILL REPEAT
IT. V. I PHONE NUMBER FOR THOSE
WISHING TO PROVIDE- COMMENT VIA
PHONE THAT PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS. 844-291-4185
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. THREE
THREE EIGHT ZERO FOUR SIX
SEVEN. AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. I SEE NO MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC YOU'RE STEPPING UP
SOME GONNA LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE THERE. I SEE NO ONE
THERE MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
ARE STILL WITH US AND I'M SURE
YOU ARE. LET ME TùYOU UP TO
INVITE MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU AND I
WILL REMIND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. THAT YOU WILL PROVIDE
US WITH YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IF ANY AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF OUR COURT REPORTER SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. GO AHEAD MR
MODERATOR. THE MOMENT OKAY WE
GO TO LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CAMILLE MAY EVEN WITH FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA. I AM- WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF OUR CONTRACT
SIMPLE THEIR DAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WE GO TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M DR KADISHA LANG
PRESIDENT OF BOTH THE STATE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
AFRICAN AMERICAN POSITION. IS
THAT OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
BRANCH OF THE NATIONAL MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE REAPPOINTMENT. OF
YOUR RANDY HAWKINS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO NOTHING Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN A MOMENT
HAVING HEARD FROM OUR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT WE
WILL NOW DO THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION-
AGAIN I DON'T SEE ANYONE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I
WILL AGAIN LOOK AT ROOM TWO ONE
TWELVE JUST TO BE SURE. I SEE
NO ONE THERE MISTER MODERATOR
IF YOU ARE PREPARED AND READY
TO GO. WE CAN HEAR FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE. IF YOU LIKE TO
COME IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN THERE AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE TODAY MISTER
MODERATOR OKAY- WELL THIS IS A
VERY DIFFERENT HEARING THAT THE
LAST TIME- WE HAD MANY MORE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WITH
CONCERNS SO MAYBE THAT SPEAKS
TO THE- TO THE PROCESS AND TO
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY THANK YOU-
SENATOR LAYERED ICE LET ME JUST
MAKE SURE- ARE BUT THE MEMBERS
OF THIS BODY OKAY IF WE TAKE
ALL FOUR TOGETHER. GREAT JUST
WHAT I WAS GOING TO ASK IF I
WOULD MOVE ALL FOUR OF THESE
NOMINATIONS SENATOR LARD IS
LAYERED HAS MADE A MOTION TO-
MOVE FORWARD THE APPOINTMENT OF
ALL FOUR MEMBERS THAT WOULD BE
DOCTOR HAWKINS. I MISS LUCIANO
MISCONDUCT VERDE AND MISTER
BROOKS MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ZERO I
WROTE I KAMLAGER LAYERED HI
LAYERED I BATES AYE BATES AYE
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE AND- WE
HAVE A MEMBER OF OUR COMMITTEE
IS AT A NOTHER COMMITTEE AT THE
MOMENT SO TO YOU WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPENED SO THAT MISS
COM LONGER SENATOR COM LONGER
CAN COME BACK IN AFTER VOTE ON
BUT YOU HAVE FOUR VOTES- THAT
MOVES YOU YOUR CONFIRMATION TO
THE SENATE FLOOR AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONVERSATION
YOUR DISCUSSION AND YOUR VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND- IMPORTANT
COMMENTS TODAY SO OUR
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL FOUR OF
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR SO MUCH THANK
YOU THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT DAY.
FORGES OKAY WE WILL- WE WILLWAKE MOMENTARILY FOR MISS COM
LONGER SENATOR CALM WATER THAT
WAY SHE CAN ADD ON HER VOTE
BEFORE WE GO INTO- OUR
EXECUTIVE SESSION- SO LET ME
MAKE SOME COMMENTS WHILE WE ARE
WAITING ON. SENATOR COM LAGER
TO REAPPEAR. THIS CONCLUDES THE
EXCEPT FOR THE VOTE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
BUT LET ME JUST MAKE COMMENTS
TO THOSE. WHO PARTICIPATED
TODAY TO THANK ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US. WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD TONIGHT
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR HELP
AND YOUR PATIENCE TODAY. AND
WITH THAT MISS COME LONGER IS
BACK SO- WE HAD A MOTION FOR
ALL FOUR TOGETHER- AND THE ROLE
IS OPEN IF YOU WERE PREPARED
SENATOR MADAM SECRETARY.
KAMLAGER HI I'M LONGER FIVE
DESERVES SO TO THE- TO THE
CONFEREES WHO ARE STILL WITH US
YOU NOW HAVE A FIVE A VOTE THAT
IS UNANIMOUS AND
CONGRATULATIONS SHARE THAT WITH
YOUR OTHER TWO COLLEAGUES THAT.
I HAVE SIGNED OFF WITH OUR
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO THIS
CONCLUDES THE PUBLIC PORTION OF
THE AGENDA SO I WANT TO AGAIN
THANK EVERYONE ARE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL NOW
MOVE TO EXECUTIVE SESSION.